All of these weirdo follow-probably Pothysan will literally tell
you with a straight face that Hassan was not shocking his dog
on stream. >> Yeah, you're wrong. You're wrong incredibly
wrong. Hassan actively encourages his audience to do things that
are more or less the equivalent of doxing, swatting
>> Let me see. This is a little preview, okay? Democrats
are handling the poll. >> Literally. We're We're at the
point where the debate has moved from should we engage with Hassan
to Hassan never engages with us
and now and and now there's nothing actionable about this debate.
This debate is totally
devolved into a drama slot panel. There's nothing actionable
being talked about here. Nothing at all. This is completely pointless
at this point and I really don't appreciate what Wick was trying
to do there. I think that that is
a really sketchy move from a moderator, frankly. Trying to do
this like uh Does Ryan think he's there for a political discussion?
Why Why would Ryan think he's there for a political discussion?
They're They're there to like try to farm clips for like the
eighth time on the same topic because they've just been losing
on this topic constantly. They're trying to maintain their death
grip on like this cult. This cult needs to see them beat somebody,
right? So, they're just going to keep running back the same topics
over and over and over again over and over and over again.
Right? Telling you Hassan's really toxic. Meanwhile, uh basically
these three guys all support doxing fully full-throatedly support
doxing anybody who [__] with you on the internet
immediately. Immediately go to doxing. They all full-throatedly
Sorry, I didn't include Destiny there cuz it was obvious. Sorry,
these four people. Like you you came up with these total moral
reprobates and you're like it almost seems like these guys aren't
looking to make the world better. It almost seems like
It almost seems like these guys aren't trying to make the world
better right now. Yeah, no No [__]
The substance also tweeted this one out apparently. Apparently,
this also went
If you want an idea of how far Twitch poll liberal discourse
has descended, Wictory's audience mostly DGG and or DGG sympathetic
think Fuentes' viewers are more gettable for Dems than Hassan
the Hun viewers. There's There just needs to be a follow-up.
This is insane, by the way. I assume that some total [__]
says this on the panel and they want like Sorry, it will be
I You're just particularly moronic if you said it, but it it
will be one of Wick, Destiny, Dan, Mouton. One of them will say
this, right? And then the poll will skew because of that, right?
Here it is. Let's go to this panel. Do Who do you think's the
greater threat right now to the Democratic Party, MAGA or Hassan?
Who's a big Wait, is that the Dude, there's no way that's the
question. Who's the biggest threat to Democrats, Hassan or MAGA?
Wait, that's the That's the question?
Is this Dude, this is crazy.
I'll remind you Destiny and anybody who takes his opinions and
skin walks them is the last person who can tell you when MAGA
is defeated or that MAGA is not a threat. Do you remember Destiny
telling you repeatedly in 2021, 2022 that the Republican Party
is dead, it will never win an election again, it will never win
with Trump again, that whole thing is dead. He said this repeatedly
over and over and over and over again even into 2023, I believe.
And now now he's going to come back and tell you, by the way,
these guys are like done. They're not even a threat anymore.
Amazing. a greater threat to the Democratic Party, MAGA or Hassan
and why? Uh MAGA. Uh just obviously. I mean, they're the ones
with all the power. They're the ones subverting the Democratic
Party. They're destroying the country. Uh Hassan, no matter what
you think his intentions are, is just not even close to the amount
of leverage that MAGA has and power that MAGA has. I think anyone
arguing otherwise is has Hassan Derangement Syndrome.
That true, Mouton? Do you have Hassan Derangement Syndrome? I
don't think I have Hassan Derangement Syndrome. Everything that
MAGA is doing right now is helping the Democratic Party. I mean,
they're doing just the dumbest things constantly. I Trust me,
I hope that's true, but why are you risking that?
Why Why would you risk that? I hope that's true. And again, is
anything they've done is it actually worse than Maybe it's worse
to the base, but is it actually worse than Dude, couple things,
okay? Is it actually worse than January
I don't In terms of America?
I don't know. It's actually It could get close. It could get
a little bit close. All right?
they have their ejection candidate. They are They are setting
up J.D. Vance to say J.D. Vance was totally against this war.
J.D. Vance is going to carry the mantle of MAGA, right? And he
is uniting By the way, the entire cohort that is behind Tucker
Carlson, Alex Jones, Candace Owens, everything outside of just
the groypers, they all align 100% behind J.D. Vance. And if J.D.
Vance is just going to be palatable to the rest of the Republican
Party, MAGA is not dead at all. MAGA is totally fine. They're
already ready. They've got their plan. They're moving on. And
Democrats are at an all-time high right now because they're being
Democrats are not at all Dude, Dude, I'm Dude, I'm actually chimping
out. I'm actually going to chimp out. I'm actually going to chimp
out. I'm actually going to chimp the [__] out. the
uh the straight-up moves. The whole now run um it is wildly unpopular
and that is what MAGA is pushing and doing right now. They're
under uh Trump's pretty much direct order uh and they're following
every every one of his whims. I don't know how to say it without
sounding mean, but why are people here who don't know anything
about politics arguing about what MAGA is doing? Already, Destiny's
like a terrible forecaster of anything that happens with MAGA.
Like a terrible unreliable forecaster. The people who just copy
Destiny's opinions like without understanding anything, why would
they be better? I guess like in terms of like who's doing more
harm to the Democratic Party, it's not like straight-up answer
is like MAGA is obviously and clearly doing more harm to the
entire country and like Democrats in general and like Republicans
like all the citizens. But in terms of a question of like who's
doing more specific harm to like the Democratic Party, I I think
it's a bit different. I feel like there's two different kind
of ways you can read that question. >> Yeah, we're not
talking about like democracy, right? We're just talking about
like the party. Which I would say Hassan is doing more harm technically.
And MAGA is actually kind of helping out right now by eating
itself. I think this is like burying the lead where it's like,
well, if the people who have ideals that are completely antithetical
and want to subvert the Democratic Party and specifically I'm
talking about MAGA in that sense. I know that can apply to both.
Uh are doing a bad job, then therefore they're less harmful.
Like maybe in the ultimate sense because they're doing a bad
job, they'll help us win the midterms. But I I don't think this
is It depends like why you're measuring this, how you're measuring
this. Like very clearly, it's not phrased in such a way that
you would think, oh yeah, like MAGA is good for the Democrats.
It's oh MAGA is awful and that's why we're succeeding. I think
I think that's not really a good way of framing it. >> My
My concern, right? Cuz you say you can't avoid these tankies
and you have to work with them. I don't I I don't know if that's
By the way, all of these people, the argument from the beginning
was shunning Hassan, cut Hassan out of the coalition. This is
an entire goalpost move that nobody here will acknowledge, right?
They've lost repeatedly on their shunning Hassan point and they've
moved the goalpost and called for another debate. And I don't
know, do you think like most people are going to go, oh now now
we're going to argue against you anyway even if you're just like,
well, people if they disagree with Hassan should interact with
them, but push back. That's what everybody thought in the first
place. You guys were the ones who hosted multiple panels and
multiple conversations about how interacting with people like
people like uh Cristobal. That's the name I was looking for.
The Cristobal interview with Slotkin was brought up multiple
times as like the reason you shouldn't engage with Cristobal,
right? You should shun her. You should cut her out of the party.
You should shun Hassan. You should cut him out of the party.
He's anti-Semitic. He's evil. He's anti-democratic. All of these
people said this about all of these leftists and now you've entirely
moved the goalpost away. You're having a completely different
conversation because you realized that you sounded insane to
everybody. When people like Hassan are going on these platforms,
he is openly saying like he said that like he's mask on and the
goal for his presentation Immediately, that claim gets made,
somebody needs to ask for that to be proven.
Hey, he's He's mask on. Could you show me the proof of that?
Show me Show me the proof of him talking about hiding it where
he openly says he's mask on and he's going to destroy the Democratic
Party or something. Show me that. Show me that immediately. presentation
on these platforms is to I guess basically get more attention
on himself. I think his audience kind of like knows this. And
then the goal is to whatever further audience he grows from that
is to convert them away from kind of like liberalism broadly
into like a more radical pipeline. So, like at best, like Hassan
is not is Hassan is not creating Democratic voters. He's not
Nobody on the right is being converted into a Democrat from Hassan.
He might grab some people from the very very far right and turn
them into like tankies or socialists, but Hassan is not converting
Hey, we've got like numbers from his audience. His audience is
by far
Democratic voters. Blue no matter who down the ticket. manosphere
people or or anybody else like So, I I would just I'd be curious
why you're saying that when by supermajority,
his his his viewers vote Kamala Harris, vote blue no matter
or like you know, MAGA people into Democrats. Why do you think
that Sorry, my bad. No, why Why do you think that like for instance,
you couldn't convert a Hassan viewer into someone that supports
the Democratic Party? Like I have people in my community that
used to be more hardcore social By the way, this all stems it's
downstream from this discussion and approach that is any criticism
of the Democratic Party, even small criticisms, even things that
are just light. Or it probably it's mostly the big discussion,
okay? The Israel-Palestine thing. But even small ones. You're
not allowed to do that. So, when Hassan takes stands and says,
I'm not going to vote for somebody who is like abetting genocide,
they go, oh, you don't support the Democratic Party.
And there's no room in the discussion for why the Democratic
Party shouldn't want to support a genocide at all? There's no
discussion. There's no room for that conversation, right? If
you're going to talk about that at all, if you mention it, you
are bad. You're not a supporter of the Democratic Party. By the
way, they also went out and voted
They still did it.
But I just I don't understand why how can the line for for a
liberal democracy believing group be if you say what your grievances
are, you're out? How could that be the line? And that is the
line. Make no mistake, that is the line. They're moving the goalposts
on Israel-Palestine now. They're moving the goalposts on what
they thought should happen with the Saudi now. But make no mistake,
we can go back. We can show this.
The line was, okay, if you call Biden like complicit in genocide,
we can't vote for him anymore, so you're you're like totally
destroying his chance to win or Kamala Harris. Right? Speaking
the truth is actually too damaging to the party.
I don't
I don't think that is a functional part of any democracy. Speaking
the truth is super damaging to the party. Right? You should be
able to do that. You should understand the downsides of voting
for Malaka or not voting at all, and those should be emphasized,
too. But in terms of saying, oh, you just can't like actually
talk about that, it's insane. Totally insane, okay? Socialists
and are now, you know, they they vote for the Democratic Party.
You know, they might hold socialist views still, but they vote
for Democrats. You know, they're no longer black pills. >> was
saying? I thought he was talking to >> Hasan doesn't do
this. >> saying Hasan can't move a guy. >> No, no,
no, no, that that's He's saying, why can't I convert to Hasan's
audience? You you can't. >> Yeah, why can't you convert
to Hasan's audience? It's it's hard, but the problem the reason
why it's so difficult is because the game is not equal. There
are infinite numbers of liberals that will run the heart the
most hardcore defense for the socialists, and then on the socialist
side, they will just openly unabashedly try to destroy every
liberal they come across. I think I just Dude, there's no way.
Like, okay, he is he is so far off.
Uh I can see this is where he's going to build the the Fuentes
thing. And he almost has a point that you could compare Hasan
and Fuentes in this one way, and that they are the far side flank
of the party. And they do target people who go against their
issues. They will say this person's very bad. On Hasan's side,
that is on Israel-Palestine. If you are a totally unapologetic
like Zionist, and you are arguing Israel needs to be supported
no matter what, they will target you. That seems pretty moral.
On the far right side, the Fuentes side, if you're not sufficiently
racist, they will target you. If you're not sufficiently bigoted,
they will target you. Right? If you go, hey, it's wrong to like
target, you know, just the Latino Americans this way, it's wrong
to target this group of they will target you.
Right? That's that's the difference. If you have an Indian wife,
yes, they will target you. And they are far more aggressive,
far more effective, far more
Right? Far more cult-like. They are every every element of that
thing is 10x with the Groypers and the far right in
So, to compare these two things would be insane. Anyway, we continue.
>> it was Hasan and Mike from PA, and I don't know if it
was FT Signifier or some other guy. They were like ranking like
the worst like right-wing people, and they put me as like S rank
for like most right-wing person. Like this is like you're just
like unhinged. I I know that's just personal to me, but like
you see this time and time and time again where the socialists
are constantly
Was it worst people or most right-wing? So, if it's just worst
people, then yeah, S rank easy. All of the polling shows the
thing that hurts even more is that all of their polling shows
that they're like really far removed from even where the moderate
Democratic voter is these days. So, the fact that they are basically
saying it's all or nothing on our primaries for our candidates,
and then we're going to become disengaged afterwards. I'm going
to spend the entire primary attacking your party with as much
of vitriol as possible. Like I thought it was really funny. I
saw Medhi Hasan tweet 2 days ago where he was like, where are
all the anti-war Which election did Medhi Hasan run in?
Which which election did Medhi Hasan run in again?
I forgot which could I just I don't remember the house seat he
ran for. Could we hear that? protest against Trump, and it's
like, good question, Medhi. You're very close to figuring that
one out. Like they were only there for Kamala and Biden. Like
yeah, that's just a >> What about that whole panel I was
on was anti-war against Trump, although a lot of them were just
on Israel. The point was we're anti what the government is doing
right now. Sure, but not like in a way that is supportive of
the Democratic Party. Like
Guys, you can't have criticisms of government without saying
the Democrats rock. That's these people have like accurate criticisms,
and what they need to do is say, the Democrats are awesome, and
they never make mistakes, but in spite of that, there's maybe
a little thing they could do a little bit better, but it's like
99% great, and I love the Democrats. That's the only way you
can engage in politics. If you engage in politics any other way,
you shouldn't be engaged with positively ever is the prescription,
and it's embarrassing. The the same people that are anti-war
that then talk about like the duopoly or the two-party, you know,
>> Party right now is kind of in not opposing the war to
the extent that the party or the progressives wanted them to.
Like they're just kind of saying, yeah, it's illegal, but well,
maybe we'll have to discuss whether or not this is a legitimate
action, not, hey, this is fundamentally wrong. That's why it's
anti-Democrat.
Uh well, but I mean like if you were opposed to the war, voting
for Kamala would would have not had us in this position. I I
agree, but that's not what the point of what I was saying was.
Dude. Just an obvious deflection. Surely the moderator Surely
the moderator is going to prioritize having a good faith conversation
and say, that wasn't even remotely a part of the question.
Right? Hey, he's saying that well, we we want Democrats to go
harder, and they're not going hard on the war at all. They're
actually being very soft. They're not going hard on the people
who crossed who crossed um uh the aisle to vote with Republicans.
They're not going hard on any of those
There's reason you should be mad, but apparently that's that's
not good enough. That's That's We're going to go in a totally
different But don't you agree that if we voted for Kamala, it
would be better? I thought you didn't need Kamala. Sorry, I thought
you didn't need leftists to win for Kamala. I thought they're
worthless. They're not a part of your coalition.
Hutch told people, hey, don't vote for Kamala. I We don't need
you. You.
was. You're saying, why are they
Uh-oh. on Democrats. It's because Democrats aren't providing
a voice for the people that are anti-war right now. I this line
of thought is is is is it just a line of thought that no other
sane political party would ever entertain. Like you can't There's
no way that you would accept a group of people who campaigned
against your candidate in the primary for months and months and
months crying and screaming and baby raging. And then as soon
as bad [__] happens when the other guy wins, all
the bad [__] that our candidate said was going to
happen, they then turn around and say, why aren't the Democrats
doing anything about it having a stronger stance about it? Like,
oh, sure, yeah. I I think the left people are going to totally
totally totally different argument again.
Just doing talking points instead of engaging with with with
what Soy Pill is actually saying. Like Well, don't get me wrong.
The idea that people say, oh my god, Democrats are feckless,
I'm not voting for them. You have to win my vote, and then complain
when the Democrats not have power to stop things. Yeah, those
are people are stupid. But the idea that these people can help
us get more progressive candidates that are anti-war and so on.
By the way, all the people they're talking about, Hasan voted
blue.
Kyle I believe argued voting blue for Kamala in like didn't endorse
Kamala officially, but literally did a bunch of pro-Kamala content,
right? And told people obviously, I think he's done this every
time, do vote do do vote swapping or something if you're in like
a um
like a swing state because your vote matters, and you should
vote blue. This is like the same thing they all do. You just
They just don't want to deal with the rhetoric. They don't want
to actually do their jobs. This is a political party who does
not want to engage in politics. Well, sorry, these are internet
who want their political party not to engage in politics at all.
Guess what? Guess how that worked out for the Republican Party
and Nick Fuentes. Well, they're alert. It went real real real
real real real real real really bad. It went really bad. I'm
going to support those candidates. Hey, maybe they're going to
give up when their candidate doesn't win, and that sucks, and
they're not even, you know, go further than that. They'll be
negative. They'll detract and drive voter apathy, and that's
bad. That doesn't mean I should give up their help in the short
term to get candidates that I want, right? I think it does cuz
you're fostering a cancerous movement inside of your own party
that's that's going to devour you from the inside or hurt you
come the Not terminating like not even an argument. Not even
an argument. Just total fantasy. I totally made up this
Total fantasy, complete fantasy, literally not a not That wasn't
an argument. That was you upending the table, right? Because
Well, they're they're they're growing a cancer in our They're
a cancer in our party, and they're going to kill us in the general.
Okay. I Why? They vote for you by and large in the general, no
matter what you
Literally, even if you cut Hasan out of the Democratic Party,
I guarantee you all of these people would still go vote
Like the the broad majority of these people would still go vote
blue. which I think that's what they're going to do. They're
going to do that They're going to do that either way, right?
No, I was going to say right now the issue is is the and you
see this the way that they're utilized right now is Hasan is
being used to attack the entire Republican Party.
By the way,
this is actually a great point. What was Destiny doing for like
the past year? Where was he during the Mondani election? Where
was he for all of this stuff for politics?
Why does he basically just come back and start getting engaged
with politics to snark on Hasan?
Wasn't he like essentially not following this [__]
at all? I feel like he was totally disengaged for months.
Maybe a full year since the Pixie thing. I remember when people
were like, hey, why aren't you doing events and stuff? Right?
He had the America tour, and that was it.
That That's it. America.
Somebody basically set everything up for him to go and speak
at South, and he he didn't follow anything, by the way. He didn't
follow political issues at all.
It's why he says so many stupid things now because he hasn't
been following politics for a year, and he gets things wrong
consistently. He has not gotten fully back engaged with this
stuff until Hasan started coming up in the media. Crazy. I'm
sorry, attack the entire Democratic Party. Like everybody sees
these people just launching platforms to attack the entire Democratic
Party. And So, what? You you have all No, no, no, no, no. Guys,
you don't understand. You don't understand. He really really
really needed to go over this Imgur album of screenshots from
the J Soc Discord. That's what That was actually critical to
democracy. Democracy starts with fighting against the J Soc Discord
and going over many screenshots of that Discord and cat gifts,
okay? Very important. Very critical. People should know that
the Republicans are going to call us communists no matter what
whether or not Hassan exists and is seen on the same platform
as you and I. Sure, I agree but you add a little bit more well
there's an issue there because one
there's more legitimacy to it which helps it carry a little bit
further but then two Hassan is also attacking the Democratic
Party from the other side. So now they're amplifying a voice
that's being used to attack the Dems, a voice that's also basically
exclusively used to attack the Dems and then um Yeah, I don't
know. I just I just don't know what like would we say in 2024
were the lefties helpful or harmful in the general to us? In
the general absolutely harmful, yeah. Then then why would we
do it again? So that hold on. Why does Soy Bill even let him
get away?
Make him say why they were harmful. Do not let him get away with
that totally thought terminating exercise terminating exercise.
Uh were they helpful or harmful? Well wait, why did they why
would lefties have pulled back from voting them?
To the degree that they were before. Why would the rhetoric It's
by the way it's not even the voters. The voters haven't pulled
back really. It's the rhetoric. Why did the rhetoric pull back?
Well I know why the rhetoric pulled back. Destiny knows why the
rhetoric pulled back but listen, apparently he's the biggest
critical the biggest critic of Israel guys. Don't you know? The
biggest critic of Israel who argued about the the cookie rockets
in Gaza.
The biggest critic of Israel.
The whole reason this happened was because people took a principled
stand on the war crimes happening in Gaza
and Democrats said no no no no no no no no it's not that important.
If you wanted to win those voters, wanted to win the rhetoric
to your side
then you should have done the right thing. But you didn't want
to do that. So you have to deal with the consequences. Have I
ever debated Destiny? Yeah, on different things but I once he
started doxxing people around me I don't engage. I'm not going
to engage. What why would we do what again? Entertain them as
being part of our movement just to have like if they were damaging
in the easy selection of all time. If they're damaging in the
general regardless of whether or not they help us in primaries
that we care about why does it matter whether or not they help
us now? How do they help you in the primary if you lose the general?
What do you mean? But they also just go and vote for the candidate
and then they don't show up in the general. I'm talking about
multiple elections. So for example wrong evidence evidence. WHY
DOESN'T SOY BILL ASK? CAN SOY BILL
Love Soy Bill, okay? Soy Bill is Soy Bill Soy Bill is my boy,
okay? Soy Bill is my boy but I need you to ask when people make
assertions ask them to cite that assertion ask them to give me
a source for that. Why do you think lefties don't vote in the
general?
Why do you think that? Cuz it doesn't apply to Hassan's audience.
Whose audience do you think it applies to?
Where where are those people? Where where are the people who
are not voting?
I just don't get it. What this is like an invented narrative
again. Example when I'm talking about that PV panel there's multiple
candidates for multiple different races that I think there's
no way I don't think you would deny that or reject all of these
candidates. You probably support a couple of these. At the very
least you understand that like people that you probably would
support like I I know you've expressed positive feelings about
AOC and Mondani like these people also are saying hey I'm going
to utilize this person to help me and just because they're not
going to vote for my candidate in the general and if not actively
detract from them they're going to do this either way. Why not
take the benefit of their incredibly large platform and incredibly
large audience to help you get the people that you agree with.
Well can I First of all AOC and Mondani don't attack other Democrats
constantly so they they would pass whatever peer whatever test
I'm neither do I but they'll work with Hassan. That's what I'm
saying. Do you do you think that maybe agreeing with some of
these people agreeing with some of these people these tankies
might cause you to lose votes among people that vote at like
twice the rate that they they will, right? Like if you go and
you capitulate to a typical
There's no capitulation to talk in talking to somebody.
Again, foundationally like point from Dan I don't know why he's
on this paddle. I that's very embarrassing for you. Like literally
the argument that other people are making is that you don't capitulate
on any of the issues. You just talk about the things where you
overlap the places you're overlapping, right? You don't move
the the issues the platform at all. You just talk and even just
disagree even like Destiny apparently says oh you should talk
to Hassan. Also says you shouldn't attack a friend to send to
some which is very funny but he says you should talk to Hassan.
You should just disagree. Young men primarily moved away from
the Democratic Party and you can say by the way that's part in
due to Hassan's driving [clears throat] a voter apathy but if
you think you can court any of those people not Hassan obviously
you're not going to court Hassan but the idea like look at the
core movement cuz I don't like these comparisons to Nick Fuentes.
You can't court Nick Fuentes's audience. Nick Fuentes is the
heart of Nick Fuentes's movement is anti-Jew anti anything but
Christian nationalism, right? But if you look at Hassan's audience
is the primary audience communism? Is the primary audience you
know like let's do Democrats.
Is this person good? Is this like the female hot chip here? Are
you watching the reactions as as Soy Bill's talking? Hold on.
I don't know if people are watching these reactions. These reactions
are crazy. You can't court Nick Fuentes's audience. Nick Fuentes
is the heart of Nick Fuentes's movement is anti-Jew anti anything
but Christian nationalism, right? But if you look at Hassan's
audience is the primary audience communism? Is the primary audience
you know like let's do Democrats. She's she's doing a lot of
like this person she's she's literally just doing a bunch of
like facial signaling that this is dumb to ask. These are all
These are all like perfectly reasonable things. You should literally
all agree on these things.
I want to hear from Dan. Dan go ahead. You're glad I think you're
glad you asked. Go ahead. I'm glad you asked because to me I
feel like Hassan's audience is nothing. It's not even political.
It's just a Che Guevara poster on the wall. It's nothing to do
with anything. It's it did America do
Hassan does infinitely more to engage with politics than Dan
does. It's particularly egregious for Dan who doesn't engage
in politics at all to call out Hassan when Hassan goes to Hassan
literally has gone to multiple speeches this year political speeches
like his own and other people's and campaigned with multiple
candidates
Hassan was the guy who started blowing up the the social media
campaign and frenzy around Zohran Mamdani.
I don't under Where are we going with
What do you mean it's just a Che Guevara poster on the wall?
That seems that seems really dismissive for no reason. Something
good I'm against it and that's that's it. There really is at
the end of the day all all there is. So there's no Che Guevara
poster on the wall nothing to do with anything. It's it did America
do something good? I'm against it and that's that's it. There
really is at the end of the day all all there is. So there's
no Did America do something good? I'm against it. Example?
I Do you think that's what happened? Is that is Dan giving us
that he actually agrees with the Iran war? That the Iran war
was good and Hassan opposes it because it's a good for America?
That's very interesting. Point negotiating with this type of
a terrorist audience that they're going to vote Democrat or not.
I don't even think Well I I need Well no no no wait Dan I need
to press you on this cuz I I I this might be true and I don't
have polling on this but if you were to ask the average Hassan
voter like the take the worst examples of what Hassan can be
pro-terrorist anti-American to like dogmatically and anti-Semitic
do you think the majority of his audience is in line with this?
Do I mean in line with what? Do you think like if you were to
ask the Dan has to argue yes because for the past like two years
he's been arguing that exact point. So he literally has to argue
yes. He can't get out of this,
He has to argue yeah they're all this way. That's why he built
all the chat the sites that show that the chat and Right? He
has to argue this. He has to argue it down. He like 60% of Hassan
voters are like pro-Hezbollah.
Okay, I I fundamentally don't think so and that might be selection
bias of me like I'm obviously just basing this off the people
I know in real life that watch him and are fans but I think when
you look at the core audience of his time they aren't tolerant
of it though,
They weren't. Trust me. Listen, gas gas is at $2 or three sorry
gas at $3.50 a gallon you're kind of like whatever. Gas starts
creeping up towards like five six $7 a gallon, all right? Uh-oh.
Then then we're in trouble, right? Oh absolutely and then which
is
hold on. Hassan has been on record it's so funny because I was
talking to someone about this earlier today. If you go through
Hassan's old VODs and you search for lesser evil voter Hassan
has said this 100 times and he says I'm I'm definitely a lesser
evil voter. I I would vote for Hamas. He says this over and over
and over again. You can't
Yeah, it's embarrassing that you support the IDF in Israel over
Hamas.
If all you care about is human life that's that's obviously true.
Claim to be naive about the idea that his audience is going to
be like yeah Hamas is better. I I like Hamas it's good. They're
they're good thing. They're the moral No, they're they're all
bad. Hamas is really bad. They're just less bad than Israel.
They are the lesser evil. To be one of the lesser evils you have
to be evil. They're just less evil than Israel. That's all. That's
it. Arbiter of the Middle East like this is something he has
said ad nauseam. Quick question for Soy Bill in the Michigan
US Senate election the primary that's going on. Do you think
Hassan is going to campaign as hard for whoever wins that he
is he is right now for that Abdul El-Sayed person? Uh no. Okay.
Isn't that a terrible thing? Shouldn't they be campaigning just
as hard? Yeah, in the general. Just as hard.
I mean only if you think people should lie. Like you could say
just say the truth. Why is that not enough?
Yeah, I you know it's not El-Sayed but it's not Maga and so you
should go vote blue no matter who in this area. Why why do you
have to go like well I love this guy. He agrees with me on everything
and then you buy into like campaigning just as hard for somebody
who wants more funding for Israeli weapons?
That's insane. That's an insane prospect. No human operates this
way.
Like, what if what if there was a bigger coalition of of pro-life
voters in the Democratic Party and you vote in the
and you don't get that you have a good idea this guy's going
to be the breaking vote to get abortion banned
Like ban harsh bans.
Right? Obviously there are there are principles that you should
uphold even when you're voting and while I would say, you know,
assuming the Trump people are still worse and I think they would
be even in both of these cases, you just go, "Yeah, I know. They're
they're like a bad person, but they're less bad than their counterpart."
And if that's not enough for you, then maybe you should try to
reassess your priorities and pick a vote somewhere else. Who's
going to be I I agree with this so but there was an interesting
question posed earlier about like a Fuentes viewer versus a Hasan
viewer. I think it would [clears throat] be easier to convert
a Fuentes viewer, I think, into like a center-left voter than
it would be to convert a Hasan viewer because in the environment
that we exist in right now, Fuentes is seen as the enemy ideologically
to our party. So when I'm having a debate with Fuentes or if
we're if our like audiences are going back and forth, the understanding
is that like we're opposed to your ideology and we're fighting
on those grounds. Whereas for the lefties, the tankies, it's
one way. It's always one way. Like there's no world where where
Fuentes or any like Candace Owens type can cry and be like, "Why
are you attacking me?" Hold on. Why does that make them easier
to win?
I can somebody explain He just said something and while that
thing might be true, how is that related to being to it being
easier to win a Fuentes view view a Fuentes voter or a Fuentes
viewer? How do you win them more easily by like on everything
they hold dear?
I I don't get it. And also with Hasan, the problem with Hasan
that he doesn't want to lay out and this is why they have to
argue that Hasan only lies and he's always lying about everything
is because they know that they're going to have to attack Hasan
on positions he actually holds, which is the Israel position,
right? That's the only one they want to attack him on that he
actually holds. Otherwise they're going to go, "Well, you're
just you want to destroy the United States. You want to you want
to destroy the United States. You want to end democracy. You
want Marxism-Leninism here in America. You want to make a vanguard
party and destroy everything."
Right? That's they'll have to just make things up and they can't
argue on those grounds. We're on the same side. Stop hitting.
Right, it's not fair. Whereas in the tankie world, Hasan and
all these guys are spending infinite all their time is attacking
Democrats constantly. But if we say anything about them, we're
punching to the If you think you can convert Fuentes viewers,
I absolutely encourage you to do it. I think that would be an
absolute positive for the world if you can get Here here's the
funny thing. If anyone was going to convert Fuentes viewers,
it's unfortunately going to be Hasan, okay? Pretty much like
you need to think you need to think Israel is a source of a lot
of problems in the world to convert a single one of those people.
None of these guys are converting a single Fuentes viewer, okay?
Maybe you could get Hasan cuz there is some element of like,
"Hey, we all we all think Israel's doing a lot of evil right
now, right?" But it would have to be breaking the the like ethnic
grounds. I think basically everybody who's a Fuentes viewer can't
go over to Hasan because they miss on every other issue. Well
well the Israel issue is a big deal. Like that's sorry, that's
the main differentiating factor, right? Like he's got that overlap.
Otherwise both the liberals and the lefties agree on like 90%
of issues outside of the Israel thing, right? But the problem
is the only the only thing where the Fuentes viewers agree is
the Israel thing.
So like Hasan is easier he is closer in that one way, but there's
that's just because you overlap nowhere else. There isn't a single
overlap for liberals and Nick Fuentes.
What are you going to Dude, what are you going to do? Nick Fuentes
does actually want to destroy democracy. Nick Fuentes does actually
want to destroy democracy. He hates it. He openly says so. It's
crazy. Fuentes is converting them right now. What what I'm saying
what I'm saying is that it would be easier to convert somebody
on the far right than the far left because that far left pipeline
is only going one way right now. On the far right it's seen as
like a mutual fight at least we're fighting on the same ground.
You say this all the time like they're never moderating, but
like if we are to take it face value that Hasan is a Marxist-Leninist
who wants to like implement communism, then is he not platforming
and capitulating and kind of seeding ground to liberals or people
at least to his right when he does support candidates like a
Bernie and AOC or Mondani who are not If you believe this, if
you believe what Destiny is saying,
right, that it only goes one way, then you should be advocating
for everybody to go talk to Hasan, right? No, I think seem really
really inverted right now. I feel like >> Is he not platforming
and capitulating and kind of seeding ground to liberals or people
at least to his right when he does support candidates like a
Bernie and AOC or Mondani who are not
No, because the support for them is tepid at best anyway. Like
he he's Dude, this is so crazy. You can't win. Dude, I This is
how you know it's like a pure hatred for Hasan that animates
Destiny cuz he should understand that he looks he totally disqualifies
himself when he says things that dumb, but he can't not say he
can't give Hasan a single thing, right? That's how much he hates
him. He should know that like, "Oh, I have to give this away.
I have to give this away cuz I sound I sound deranged unless
I give this away, right?" But he can't. He he it's just there's
too much there. He is he has too much hatred. He can't even he
can't look at it, you know, in any sort of like distanced objective
way. He's just like this guy. He's like trying to calculate how
to this guy over maximally and it's funny little moments like
that just give it away. Shouldn't you want these guys these people
to talk to Hasan?
No, no, no, no, no cuz the support for them is tepid. Well, now
you're just arguing exercising again, right? Oh well, if AOC
and Bernie don't talk to him, who's supposed to talk to him?
I don't get it. What are we what are we doing here? If AOC and
Bernie aren't supposed to talk to him, who's supposed to talk
to him? far left they're never like they're never having the
conversation of like what should we give to the liberals. It's
literally all or nothing on everything. Like you've got one of
the funniest clips I remember watching Austin and Hasan were
watching Kamala Harris and Kamala Harris was saying like we need
to call for an immediate ceasefire in Gaza to, you know, get
this war stopped so we can and you know, Austin was like happy
for a second cuz he didn't get the Hasan talking points and then
I mean, an immediate ceasefire. What's what's the honor rate
on Israel and ceasefires? How often do they honor ceasefires?
What is what is Dude, Israel's like Cartman, okay? They call
time out. They they hit you, they call time out. And then you
like relax for half a second, they call time in and hit you again.
All right? That's that's Israel's plan. So when she says, "Oh,
we need a ceasefire immediately." that we're never going to hold
Israel to, that we're never going to force them to honor, that
they will never honor, everybody in the world knows that that
means nothing.
That literally means nothing every single time. Hasan is like,
"Oh, it's just another temporary ceasefire. Like this isn't even
going to be permanent. They're probably not going to do it."
It's like nothing is good enough for these people. You can never
capitulate enough to them. They they're always using these issues.
They don't care about Israel-Palestine. They just use it as an
issue to attack the left and that's all they do. Like the idea
Ooh, how long did this guy follow Israel-Palestine for, by the
way? It's so amazing. These people like care. You could say they're
soy. You could say they're losers. You could say they got nothing
better nothing else better to do, but they do actually care about
this issue. It's so crazy to say that they have like a performative
or cynical engagement with this topic. They all obviously care.
Destiny can't imagine caring about anything.
Destiny can't care about anything and so he projects that onto
everybody else and makes this argument, "Oh, it's just cynical.
They just want to on Democrats."
Okay. I I That seems that makes no sense whatsoever, but you
know, whatever whatever. >> keeping a a coalition like
that
Unless those teenagers are blood related, yes, Placido, true.
others like impossible when it's always one way and it is with
these people. It's always one way. You know >> Wait, why
why does it Wait, hold on. I I want to address that cuz you you
keep saying it's only one way, but you you did address and kind
of acknowledge the point that clearly Hasan and definitely his
audience is is in some way moderating their more radical beliefs
or at least Hasan's more radical beliefs to support progressive
candidates that are left, you know, of liberals, but like are
still in the liberal coalition that still wants social democracy.
>> You're you're talking about you're talking about the
furthest left people in the entire party. They're using these
as anchor points to pipeline people to radical ideology. That's
it. Who cares if we both want that? >> I can't No, because
we don't want that. We don't want people to become socialists
and tankies or at least I don't. Do you want Do you like those
can like do you like Bernie Sanders like would you vote for Bernie
Sanders? I
Yes, but you know what you're up against
Should I Should I deny Hasan's promotion of Bernie Sanders? No,
but that's not what we're talking about. They can promote It
is that's exactly what I'm talking about. I want to If I want
to appear on a platform to promote Bernie Sanders and say you're
in the tent for promoting Bernie Sanders, is that bad? >> We're not
talking about them
>> I don't know why you're making good arguments against
what I'm saying. I don't know why you're doing this right now.
I'm just going to keep talking over you until you stop making
arguments that I don't want to contend with. I Okay. supporting
the candidates. We're talking about us supporting Now Soy Pill
is still enough on the plantation, it seems like, that he is
he's going to stop in that situation. I don't know why personally.
I I don't know why. Little weird, but hey, he's I'm I'm just
here cuz you know what? I'm here to show everybody that we can
we can do incrementalism in the snark left space, okay? We can
do incrementalism. Soy Pill is not perfect, but he's our best
champion right now,
>> We can do incremental Look. Look. We love this guy,
okay? We love this guy. them and welcoming into our coalition.
Wait, what does that look like then? We have having friendly
campaigns alongside them or pretending that we share some >> I
just said. It's what it's me and Hasan going and Sharing Did
HE JUST SAY SHARING FRIENDLY campaigns beside them? campaigns
alongside them or pretending >> Wait, what does that look
like then? We have having friendly campaigns alongside them or
pretending that we share some kind of what I
There's no way. THERE'S NO WAY. SO, I pill was just saying this.
Are you You're saying that I would I would wouldn't be able to
go to some event to promote Bernie if Hasan was at it. That's
not what I'm saying at all. And then Destiny started talking
over him until he let him go. And then Destiny gets to go and
he says What And so, he passed What does that mean that you don't
want to you know have them be a part of this? Well, you can't
share positive campaigns with them. You can't pretend
That's that.
There's no argumentation at all. It's like this person is so
bad at arguing. I understand a lot of these people who watch
Destiny used to just watch like barely paying attention. So,
I understand it's like difficult for them to follow the arguments.
I used to watch paying attention all the time. This [__]
I would have been banned from his chat. If I was still a fan
of his, which couldn't happen, but let's say none of that [__]
happened, right? None of that [__] that with like
Pepsi and all the other people went down. Let's say none of that
happened.
I would get banned over this conversation. This is such insanely
engagement. It would be garbage to watch. I just said it's was
me and Hasan going and promoting Bernie Sanders. You said So,
I shouldn't do that. Well, let me let Hold on. Let me Hold on.
Wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait Hold on. You opened
that thing saying should Bernie Sanders not accept the support
from Hasan [__] And then you said no. And then do
we have Oh, hold on. Destiny's trying to rewrite history.
Uh-oh. Hold on. We have I don't think we have it yet. I'll go
back. We'll just see if you can find it. >> don't want
that. We don't want people to become socialist tankies, or at
least I don't. Do you want Do you like those camp Like do you
like Bernie Sa- Like would you vote for Bernie Sanders? I watch.
Watch? Yes, but you have to my words against though. These are
the >> Should I Should I deny Hasan's promotion of Bernie
Sanders? No, but that's not what we're talking about. They can
promote anything. >> That's exactly what I'm talking about.
I want to If I want to appear on a platform to promote Bernie
Sanders So, he's saying deny Hasan's
uh promotion of Bernie Sanders. And what he means there is like
basically not not be a part of any promotion Hasan's doing. Be
easy. He elaborates here, right? So, we'll listen to him elaborate.
It is. That's exactly what I'm talking about. I want to If I
want to appear on a platform to promote Bernie Sanders and and
say you're in the tent for promoting Bernie Sanders Is that We're
not talking about them supporting the candidates. We're talking
about us supporting them and welcoming into our coalition.
So, he's saying I can't go and be a part of some some event with
Hasan [__] at it. Like PV. Cuz he's talking about
PV, right? That's the grounded example he's using. He got [__]
on for doing the PV stuff, right? And
He got [__] on for doing the PV stuff. And so, that's
what he's trying to ground it to. So, I can't do events with
PV. He just said it before this, right? I can't share space with
these people.
And Destiny says, "No, that's not what I'm talking about at all."
Wait, what does that look like then?
We have having friendly campaigns alongside them or pretending
that we share some >> that is exactly what I just said.
Like PV. Like PV. It's was me and Hasan going and promoting Bernie
Sanders. You said So, I shouldn't do that. Well, let me let Hold
on. Let me Hold on. Wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait Hold on. You opened that thing saying should Bernie Sanders
not accept the support from Hasan [__] Yeah, and
then I said and then I moved on. Okay, should me and Hasan appear
on a panel promoting Bernie Sanders? That's not okay. I would
I would say that appearing on a panel with somebody with a massive
ideological Uh >> opposition to you and pretending otherwise,
I think is So, he we moved the goalpost again. Okay, I I don't
know What do you mean pretending otherwise? He means you have
to scream at Hasan about how he's a tankie
the whole time.
Literally just focusing on your similarities, bad. Don't do that.
Let's him in. generally bad. I would say generally speaking What
does pretending otherwise look like? Because in my >> you're
not empathizing your disagreements. You're only going there just
to talk about like some superficial agreements you have. It's
not superficial. It's we both want this candidate who's promoting
progressive values. That's not superfi- That's I core to my ideology.
And I'm still allowed to say, "Hey, I think this Like by the
way, I'm not trying to like play defense for things that we all
agree with, which is Hasan supports terrorist groups." What Go
ahead. Would Would you do friendly panels with Nick Fuentes right
now? This I already addressed. He should just bite this bullet
that if Nick Fuentes was out advocating his entire audience sincerely
sincere shifted beliefs, right? And you just have the old [__]
to deal with. Yeah, I I go out and I don't care. And I I will
differentiate on anything.
He should bite that bullet, but I don't think he'll bite that
bullet. >> this. The answer is no, and the answer is because
his audience is fundamentally and the core of his movement is
fundamentally opposed to me, and I don't believe that Hasan Hasan's
How
Yeah, so it's it's just about That's why he was bringing this
up earlier. It's about the audiences to him. Okay, if you're
trying to reach out to the audience, they're not fundamentally
opposed to you. Yeah, they're they're like aligned with you in
like 90% of ways. That's the argument. Okay. I'm saying like
for Fuentes if cuz I think Fuentes is like a cult leader. I think
he could shift people pretty hard.
But you know, it's it's not really important. I think that's
a perfectly good argument that you could engage with, right?
Asking that when the majority position within this audience is
Nick is getting is more gettable is
Like they should all They should answer that in the opposite
direction. Destiny needs to answer that. Yes, I would absolutely
rather campaign with Nick Fuentes than Hasan [__]
Those voters are far more gettable than Hasan Piker's voters,
right? Those viewers are way more gettable. So, he should think
the opposite for Nick Fuentes. He should think that yeah, I could
go with those people. Those Those people are gettable. No? audience
is fundamentally opposed to me. >> Hold on. Hold on. No
no no Stop stop stop stop stop Soy pill Soy pill. If Nick Fuentes
endorses the Democratic candidate coming up in >> He already
did. He's like, "I'm going to vote for Trump." >> I I want
Let me Let me finish. He's going to have done more to help Democrats
than Hasan did. It's true. You understand that, correct? >> I
don't. I I I You don't? That depends on how much he can mobilize
his machine. It's possible. In terms of achieving Democrat victory,
it is possible Nick Fuentes would suppress voters more than any
individual Democratic influencer could entice voters to go vote.
That's possible. It's not really helping Democrats,
so to speak. It might be helping Democrats like
get by on really bad ideas. But it it might suppress the vote
enough that it does something. Maybe. Maybe that's the argument
you would be making. Is he suppressing Republican votes more
than he's actually Cuz I don't think most people are going to
go vote for Democrat. In fact, you could probably argue that
he doesn't sincerely mean vote Democrat. He probably just means
don't go vote for these shills. Don't go vote for these liars.
Right? It's an expression of fear of frustration that could be
fixed by the right person. If you think that Hasan did a full-throated
endorsement of the Democrat in the primary and Nick Fuentes did,
you think more of Nick Fuentes' audiences would vote for the
Democrat? No, but probably more of Nick Fuentes' audience would
not vote for Republicans, which counts in some sense as votes
for Democrats. I think more of I think it would be easier to
radicalize a Fuentes viewer to vote against whatever the next
Republican candidate is than it would be to mobilize like a Hasan
viewer to vote for like an established The funny thing here is
you know this isn't true.
And you know that Hasan's viewers are largely animated by anti-war
bias, and that is a huge sentiment in America. That's the entire
argument of Tim Miller. You can't really make this
anywhere near as easily. You guys are like opposed to these people
on the anti-war line. You're You're like kind of trying to capitulate
in the most measured way. It's funny cuz what Destiny's doing
actually perfectly mirrors what Candace Owens and Tucker Carlson
did when they saw the wind shifting, right? Do you guys notice
that how it perfectly mirrors what Candace and Tucker did? How
they put that skin on immediately and they're like I just can't
imagine being behind any war. I just It's like fundamentally
non-Christian to be for war. War is like really bad, man. It's
like the same thing. But with with Candace and Tucker, it's always
like capitulating just a little bit and a little bit and a little
bit, just trying to do the right amount of capitulation, right?
Tucker, I think maybe that analysis has changed. It's the analysis
we used before. Maybe that analysis changes now that they're
thinking they need the 25th Amendment Trump. I think that's where
it's changing up. But it's very funny. It's like the initial
like weird and inexplicable
ideology change is very
establishment Dems. >> Someone they don't care about. That's
the vibe that I get. Fuentes stays on the same road. Now, it
might be different. Fuentes Fuentes isn't a good faith actor,
I don't >> I was going to say that it's the anti-war thing.
That's That's like the big thing is anti-war, anti-Israel in
a lot of respects, right? Anti-war, anti-genocide. Stop supporting
Israel's war in the Middle East. Please.
And you have credibility there, but if you're going to If you're
going to cut out like some of the biggest voices in that camp
and specifically target them with no real Honestly, you guys
don't have a real argument here. It's just that you they criticize
Democrats.
I guess.
I think you start to lose those anti-war people, which is the
argument Tim made, which is the argument Destiny agreed with.
So, now I don't even understand what we're doing here cuz it's
again a He's like cu- I guess
going back on that whole conversation.
Right. I don't think that we can trust Wait What do you mean?
No, I think he's pretty honest about what he means. Nick Fuentes
like is like his entire movement is fundamentally anti-Democratic,
anti-anything but Christian nationalism, right?
Hasan Hasan Hasan is anti-West. Hasan is pro-terrorist. Hasan
is like Dude, can we just go play the the clips of Nick I This
is what you have to do. And I keep saying this, and I'm starting
to not appreciate the lack of motion here. Get the racist Fuentes
clips and put them next to the racist Hasan clips and ask people
who seems more extreme. I want you to put that in front of Destiny
or Mouton or Dan or any of these people and get them to go, "This
is the same guy. This is like the same guy."
Absolutely wild, okay? Fuentes believes in race realism at a
base level. Does Destiny not realize that the exact way he attacked
Fuentes during that summer panels with Sneako and Aba and Young
Don and all of these people was on race realist lines? Do you
believe that Hasan [__] is a race realist, Destiny?
Do you believe he drives his policies based on race realism,
on ethno-nationalism?
No. Who's the person that in recent memory on the left has been
arguing in favor of ethno-nationalist ideas? Cuz it's not Hasan
[__]
Maybe think about that. Maybe that's what he means when he says,
"Oh, I can win." Maybe that was what he was trying to do. He's
trying to win some Fuentes voters in the last one of these Hasan
is bad panels. Hey guys, you know, they need the ethno-states.
Ethno-states aren't so bad. They're not They're not so bad. Like
an ML, right? And yet, if you go into his audience, when you
accuse him of being a commie anti-semite, the reason that a majority
of people start defending him is not cuz they're like all gaslighting
you. It's because a majority of them are part of this like progressive
like, "Oh, I want to just like be anti-establishment and move
the country further left." And there are tankies and there are
communists, but I'm not really sympathetic or understanding of
the idea that he has this like big communist movement. Like I
don't see that I'm pretty sure that if you were to go into Hasan's
chat and all of the communist people. This is like saying that
uh this would be like saying Trump has all the anti-semitic voters
in his coalition.
Right now. Right? It's like Sure. So, you could say that cuz
like superficially, maybe those people like did vote for Trump.
But realistically, they're all in They're all in breakaway camps,
right? They're all in breakaway camps further right from from
Trump. You're like lying basically cuz they used to vote for
him. I know with the pause. I get it. But they're lying in a
in in some sense, right? Cuz the actual communists are all people
with like bad They're people with bad empennada, with FD Signifier,
people who criticize Hasan from the left. And when you bring
up like would go on a platform with Nick Fuentes, it's like,
"Well, Nick Fuentes doesn't have an audience that I can win over.
Nick Fuentes' audience is fundamentally anti everything I stand
for, and I don't think that's the case with Hasan." And that's
what it's important when you talk about these influencers. Do
you stand for American
>> Moderator, by the way. >> Hasan fundamentally
and his audience fundamentally are against Just cuz I yell, it
becomes true. I'm yelling at you, so now it's true. The thing
I said is true. Um I don't know if things have changed much in
the past 10 years, but like I I remember on dating in California
that if somebody says they're socialist, if you talk to them
like 2 seconds, they're basically just like a liberal that wants
like more government [__] My guess is the majority
of people that watch Hasan like on Instagram reels or have like
seen a couple videos are probably in that group of just like
liberals, right? Or or are they like far They're like far left
liberals, would be my guess. But those are not the people on
Hasan's stream, which is a different audience. And Hasan is trying
to take all those like broadly speaking those liberals and try
to move them like down the like tankie pipeline. Like that's
his goal. Hasn't he literally said this in a clips? >> I
think I just remain a little confused why we think that it's
impossible for it to go the other way. Like why do we think I
I watched your stream with Francis Fukuyama
uh yesterday.
And I have to say I left like a little depressed
um because
and Francis Fukuyama, frankly, both
a little dismal about the possibility
of like really convincing people that liberalism is is a good
thing on the merits. Because nobody has any strong defenses of
liberalism anymore. And the right is Nobody has No, nobody has
any strong arguments uh for liberalism. That's the problem.
The only argument for liberalism is it created the best circumstances
we've ever had as humanity, which is a great argument. But then
when people's living standards start to go down, that argument
falls apart. That argument is great until people's quality of
life starts to drop. And then you say, "But the status quo is
great for all of us. But the status quo is great for all of us."
And they watch their lives get worse and worse and worse and
worse. And then they watch Destiny 2024 go, "The economy isn't
worse. It's actually just you being a whiny Stop ordering food,
whiny And it gets worse and worse and worse and worse. And you're
going, "The status quo is great. The status quo is great. The
status quo is great." Well, the status quo isn't great for most
of the people who vote in America right now. That's why both
parties are underwater, by the way. It's because the status quo
is not working for Americans ever.
Sorry, ever I right now. I don't know why I said ever. I was
trying to be hyperbolic. It's just not working at all. And it's
not going to work for a long time. All of the reasons the status
quo is slowly being like degraded in America, all of the reasons
it's slowly getting worse and worse over time, none of those
are being addressed. This is actually something I lost my mind
about when I used to watch Destiny was I would say automation's
really going to [__] with people. And he would go,
"Well, lump of labor fallacy."
Where How is the lump lump of labor fallacy protecting American
jobs right now? It's not. Americans are getting assed right now
in the job market.
is is fully authoritarian out of their mind. And then on the
left we have to do >> Yeah, but it's not But Hasan is not
a liberal. And we're spending all our time on the left trying
to figure out who we should court MAGA light on the left. And
we And there are no You can't even come up and defend anything
on the center left. A defense of Harris or Biden is a joke. You
look like a loser doing it. Uh It's cuz you're importing people
who took Coke money in like 2022, as in the Koch brothers thought
it was a good investment to give them money. that their ends
would be achieved by giving those people money.
Now, I think with Sara Longwell, though, I I will say there's
a little bit of me that's like, "Okay, but I think she was a
pollster." I do think it's like you're going to pull things in
a way that works for us, right? Like she clearly has an ideal
ideology that doesn't really overlap with Democrats.
It just doesn't.
So. I do watching. You know, anybody that's on Hasan's team and
even like a lot of like just younger people or people that are
online who are these populist people, the Epstein class, people
like Ro Khanna push this idea, is all the liberals. Everybody
thinks like Nancy Pelosi was a corrupt inside trader. Like everything
is like [__] on the center left. And so instead of
even I think this all plays into the argument of like, "Do we
court these people?" It's like instead of ever building out a
strong center left identity, the center left just eats itself
and then talks about having to court the the far left that has
no two-way street with the with the center left. And then you
So, you get people like Hasan who are talking about the duopoly,
the two-party system that is all the same. And then the New York
Times or center left libs are writing hit pieces on Gavin Newsom.
And I'm like, "What the [__] is happening? There
is no like liberal representation anywhere." And And again,
Not shocking to me. By the way, this is
>> Notice how Destiny's arguments tend to trend towards
being a lying degenerate scumbag is no problem. Being a totally
two-faced lying degenerate scumbag is awesome, actually. Cheating?
That's really cool. Destiny loves talking about how cheating
really isn't that big a deal. Loves talking about how Gavin Newsom
totally flipping his ideals at the drop of a hat is no big deal.
Loves it. Guys, have you noticed how like lying is not a big
deal? You shouldn't really get that mad when you're lied to.
Only the people with absolutely no self-worth take this argument
seriously. You to be convinced that cheating is not a problem,
lying is not a problem, Gavin Newsom flipping his principles
at the drop of a hat is not a problem, you have to have no self-worth.
You have to have no self-confidence. You have to be a totally
like wretched broken person.
Very sad. Very, very sad. >> And anyone who is saying that
the Democrats are struggling or failing or not doing enough,
etc., we are putting up wins. Actually, he's the victim and when
he shared pictures pixies
that with a with somebody he thought was 18, who he'd known for
7 days, had never done any a proper verification with at all,
right? When he shared of Pixie with that person, he thought he
had Pixie's consent. For sure. For for sure. For >> win
after win after win after win It's like a requirement to operate
in the DGG sphere. It's a requirement to think that you don't
deserve the truth on anything. That lying is awesome. You have
to be totally soulless. It's very sad, man. It's just It's actually
depressing to watch. the elect uh at the ballot box. Like we've
flipped what, 31 seats now? 30 seats now? Like the idea that
the Democrats aren't doing a phenomenal job, with what they have,
is amazingly
out of touch.
It's like North Korean TV.
Kim Jong Un today
create billion new jobs.
Thank you, dear leader. Thank you.
This is EXACTLY IT'S SO FUNNY that this happens right after my
whole talk about the status quo. You You can't do You are literally
literally rearranging Okay, literally in a figurative way. Rearranging
deck chairs on the Titanic.
The status quo is failing. People's lives are getting worse and
worse and worse. And you're going, "The Democrats are doing fantastic
job. And we've got everything We're going to be totally great
if we just keep doing exactly what we were doing, guys."
Guys, I know that the polling with a Republican president who's
historically unpopular is actually historically
terrible for Democrats.
I don't take any message away from this. I take away the message
the Dems are doing a great job when we're plus 5% on the Republicans
who are openly corrupt. Trump threatened the Pope. The Iran war
got started and now has destroyed the the global energy market.
Prices are about to rise massively. And you're doing plus five.
You're doing plus five. Plus five.
How? And this is the insidious nature I think of courting Hasan
or playing nice with Hasan, etc. Just to be clear, not courting
Hasan. I don't think anyone thinks that we're going to convince
>> Certainly. But there are a lot of people who want to
like kind of tolerate him within kind of the sphere. Maybe not
you specifically,
right? But there are people out there like a totally disconnected
sphere as well now at this point. Where like these people get
captured and they never get exposed to any other ideas. Like
do you think Do you think Ro Khanna in his head is going, "I'm
going to never change any of my opinions. My opinions don't align
with Hasan. I don't align with Hasan. I'm never going to change
any of my opinions, and I'm going to totally bilk this guy out
of his viewers and they're going to vote for me." Do we think
Ro Khanna thinks that? Or we think maybe just maybe like Adam
Aukler,
he realizes he overlaps with Hasan in a whole bunch of different
ways and he actually thinks like Hasan's got some good ideas?
Maybe? Maybe? May- Maybe? No? Well, I don't know. Fundamentally
I just think that liberalism is a is a strong enough ideology
and a convincing enough ideology
to win people over. I think The fact of the matter is and you
have to you have to decide on this basically. I I do believe
this to be the case right now and I don't know
I don't know how to get around it. You need some possible possibly
illiberal interventions that feels like to get liberalism to
be the thing that drives humanity forward again. I and I I'm
not even advocating for it cuz I I'm kind of principally committed
to the idea of something like liberalism, something like democracy,
but right now I don't see how you change things through a liberal
framework given that voters are basically like massively brainwashed
cattle at this point. Like democracy is sort of failed in that
way. And the status quo that exists is going to consistently
leak away standard of like quality of life from the anybody but
the top like 1% the people who have collected all of the resources,
right? Who can who can basically have either have a ton of assets
invested in these the all these companies that are actually making
money, right? Like it's going to consistently collect like your
ability to be a world beater as somebody with just like a high
intellect is
Your ability to eke out a like good life as somebody with an
average intellect is dropping and I don't see that trend reversing
without some sort of intervention and I don't know if there's
a liberal intervention that can come in come in like fix it.
I don't know. I haven't seen the argument for it. I just haven't
I haven't seen the argument for it. So I I'm probably on the
side of like well if if democracy has failed then we go down
with the ship, but I don't necessarily think the people who say
something else who say like actually we need to try to do this.
So long as they have a plan I don't think they're totally wrong.
That's just me. That's possible. I think you can win over a lot
of people who see clips of Hasan on Instagram reels like Steven
said and and say like, you know, I am really mad about Israel.
I am really mad about the fact that we don't have universal health
care. I don't I mean whenever you watch Bernie and AOC and even
Hasan whenever he gives speeches the applause lines are not like
class war now. The applause lines are not let's seize the means
of production. The applause lines are we need a right to universal
health care. We need a right to a good paying job. You know,
this is a fundamentally liberal framing. >> I mean sometimes
the applause line What just just one just Sometimes the applause
Ryan, Ryan, let him say what the applause line is for cuz the
applause line is going to be for we need a total defunding of
the state of Israel or something like this and and I I don't
know. That's what I think it's going to be. Oh, it's no, it's
going to be you know, I of course we stand with the brave fighters
in Houthis or something like that. is hey, you know, if you call
these senators and threaten them, you know, they're not going
to run for re-election. So sometimes the applause Wait, did that
happen? Did Hasan go call John Fetterman and threaten him right
now and maybe he won't run again? Did did Hasan say that? Call
me crazy. I feel like probably Hasan didn't say You know what
I'm saying? Probably not. >> Like there's like 50 million
abhorrent things that these people are saying. I'm only fighting
on like 10 of them and then I'm trying to have a good time and
then people see me as like pretty reasonable, but then when they
come to my platform I'm obviously a lot more radical against
a lot of these things, but that's like the goal of like converting
people in that direction. But then but you can never to Hasan.
Hasan won't let you do that on his platforms cuz they know that
the game that they're playing is only one way. But you just know
you just said he goes on platforms where he has to moderate.
Maybe he won't do it on his platform, but he's clearly then moderating
and capitulating to liberal ideas because he knows he has to.
So where is he now? He's only going Wait wait he's only going
to larger platforms. Notice how Hasan doesn't platform any of
you guys. Notice how Hasan doesn't platform Vaush. Notice how
Hasan doesn't deal with any smaller creators that aren't fully
in his camp. The only time Hasan's moderating is when he's going
to larger platforms so that he can try to draw people in from
there and then radicalize them when he's got them on his native
platforms. That's how he operates. People try to when they That
you're just describing networking.
You're you're literally just describing networking. I Are we
He He does this all the time where you like describe a very innocuous
practice. You like meet somebody for the first time. You're you're
talking to a group you haven't spoken to before. You're going
to find out what they like and try to find places you agree with
them and say, "Hey, I want to emphasize these agreements." That's
what literally everybody does. I Yeah? What What's the criticism?
That if Hasan were like truly honorable he would go and have
those same discussions in like other places where he would get
grilled?
I don't know. I don't know if there's like honor to it. He just
like I'm sure there are lots of people in the Dem party who don't
do like ultra far right maga media cuz they just don't want to
get like grilled all over some random issue. No? I still don't
even get it. I think that by going on these larger platforms
I mean even Tim Miller said this. There are Hasan viewers that
watch Tim Miller. I don't know if Tim Miller's larger than Hasan,
but they don't watch Tim Miller and think, "Oh, I hate this guy.
I'm not a fan of him." It's, "Hey, like this guy says things
I like when Hasan goes on here or he talks about Hasan I'm exposed
to Tim Miller's ideas. watching Tim Miller and actively trying
to court him over and then anytime they have anybody that they
disagree with on they attack them vehemently. We saw this with
Sarah Longwell on Twitter.
vehemently
Okay.
Sarah Longwell is like a Republican. Sarah Longwell is not the
argument you This is This is not the argument you want to make,
man. Okay? Sorry, I'm going to address this substance thing.
I have been saying this substance you just might not have caught
it on the stream. If Hasan goes on mainstream platforms and goes
mask on, doesn't that mean larger audiences who are sympathetic
to Hasan will then in turn be sympathetic to the positions him
and Dems agree on? You would think so if there's a if there's
a concern, right? Or it could happen. Either it happens one of
two ways. Either he has people on his platform and they argue
with him more vehemently like like more egregiously. Right? They
disagree on a bunch of stuff or he goes on other platforms and
he basically makes his audience more amenable to those ideas.
I'm not sure like he he opens them up to anybody who's talking
with him like saying, "Oh, this is what I believe in." Right?
Or they watch Hasan go on those platforms and if somebody goes,
"Yeah, I just really believe in like the capitalist organization
of the economy." Hasan's going to have to go
"Oh, well, yeah, I guess maybe you could think that." And then
he looks weak to his audience, right? That's the whole point.
viewers are watching Tim Miller and actively trying to court
him over and then anytime they have anybody that they disagree
with on they attack them vehemently. We saw this with Sarah What
did they What did they disagree on? What did What did they disagree
on?
It was the It It is Israel Israel isn't real. Okay? It was the
Israel question.
Which everybody refuses They never ever say, right? You could
tell I Why don't they ever say? Just say.
He was like, "No, Hasan's too anti-Semitic to engage with. We
have to attack him over Israel right now."
That was the whole thing. And then by the way, Destiny totally
disagreed with that. Destiny was like, "No, attacking Hasan over
anti-Semitism is stupid."
Speaking of trying to look more moderate. When I bring people
on my platform I agree I argue with them really aggressively.
Oh, yeah, I totally agree with you, Tim. Hasan is like not anti-
Hasan is like anti-Semitic, but you should never attack him over
it. Meanwhile, Destiny's friends Destiny's friends Sarah Longwell
on Twitter. She had a conversation with Tim where they had a
friendly disagreement and they immediately went to Twitter and
absolutely thrashed her and brought up like the most bad faith
arguments that you could possibly bring up against her. And not
just also not just the audience, but all of the other people
who are part of like the the tankies All of the other not just
the audience, but the other tankies. Did I even attack Sarah
Longwell on Twitter? I feel like I'm I feel like I'm about to
get invoked potentially. Maybe it's just Medhi and and some other
people. Maybe Medhi and Kyle and Crystal. Maybe that's it. the
cult, right? Ryan Grim was out there doing it.
I don't know if Manny Hasan joined that Tail of the Dragon was
out there. There were a ton of those like big people who the
pinball machine went off and they all started coming Wait Wait,
were they attacking Sarah Longwell?
Ryan Grim said, "I don't trust Sarah Longwell to not be like
a fifth column in our party." saying to Democrats because she's
taken like Koch brothers money. The Koch brothers were funding
her her little consulting group there for years before she came
over to the Dems.
That's a totally coherent argument. That's at least that's even
more coherent than any of the arguments people have made about
Hasan being like a dangerous Marxist-Leninist who's going to
destroy democracy.
Cuz you know why? Ryan Grim had money to prove up what he was
saying. Is he calling Grim Ryan Grim a tankie? Isn't Ryan Grim
literally a tankie though? I thought Ryan Grim was literally
a tankie. I thought that was the guy that was like, "No, no,
no, he actually is a Marxist-Leninist." hanging out to on to
Sarah Longwell.
Yeah, that's just what they do. Not surprising though. That's
how That's how social media works. Whenever Hasan says something
dumb I mean everyone everyone was complaining whenever Hasan
talked about like What did he say on on Jennifer Welch's podcast
that J.D. Vance and Gavin Newsom are like there's no difference
between them? Well hope There is a difference. J.D. Vance apparently
openly anti-war. Gavin Newsom I can't tell. Hold on. [laughter]
No. Hasan got a lot of defense for that comment as well. Keep
in mind the majority of the people on the far left don't think
Hasan was electrifying his dog to keep it in frame. There were
a lot of people that stepped up to defend Hasan on that. >> a
lot of He got a And also Sarah Longwell got defense as >> Welch.
I
don't know how much she got. She's getting a little bit now because
unfortunately the only the only other organized group of people
in this country are the goddamn
Jews, okay? Who have [laughter] like taken to being anti-Hasan
because of the anti-Semitic thing, which is annoying as [__]
to me, but they're the only other organized people to do it.
So in that sense there were people that have kind of come out
on Hasan, but it's only on the anti-Semitism part. I don't think
there's a similar bell you can ring when when liberals are getting
attacked especially by the far left. I think the easiest example
of that is Krystal. And also Sarah Longwell got defense as well.
Look at Jennifer Welch.
I don't know how much he got. She's getting a little bit now
because unfortunately the only the only other organized group
of people in this country are the goddamn
okay who are like taken to being anti because of the anti-Semitic
thing which is annoying as to me but they're the only other organized
people that do it which is annoying as to me.
Like you're not going to be getting these people to go and vote
Democrat. And if they were they were going to vote Democrat anyways.
So all you're doing is putting the most idealistic Green Party
views that you're not going to be able to adopt as a run-of-the-mill
Democrat and there it's like this is not your it's not your friend.
These aren't this is a an enemy of your
candidate. This is someone that wants you to lose so that you
can win. So you're trying to court third party voters it's just
better to go out and get like people who don't vote to try. Yeah
that. Here's my question because we moved past this and I wanted
to bring it up and I I know by the way this is not a That was
incredible. That was totally
>> So the strategy then if that were the only problem you
would just ignore
That's that's the issue right? If you just thought they were
going to vote for you anyway which Dan just said which goes against
what everybody else is on this panel has been arguing the entire
time. Dan just undercut them. Right? The strategy there would
to be would be to ignore them. The reason you go after them is
cuz you do agree with them on so many things. You can win them
on so many
The reason you're mad is because the one issue you don't want
to capitulate on is the one issue that they won't capitulate
on. And you're literally just throwing a temper tantrum about
it. That's what this whole time has been. The entire time it's
just been that. criticism. I think it was a valid thing to do
that seems to be the same thing on the other
Do we platform never Trump Republicans who make it clear that
they would never vote for Democrats other than to vote against
Trump and and >> Yes. I would say you should you shouldn't.
Uh Dan tell us why you say yes. Mr. Mouton tell us why you say
you shouldn't. Okay. >> I think that you can be strategic
about this both ways. Like right now people be like oh are you
happy you know now Republicans are using Hassan. I say well that's
great because one of the reasons that Clinton won was his sister
Soldier moment where he came out and he showed himself to be
a centrist a moderate as opposed to other people who weren't
willing to rebuke Jesse Jackson at that moment. So he Hassan
can be a lightning rod to be like listen I'm not a [__]
crazy lefty that's going to make you use 600 pronouns and and
a kitty cat box when you go to school. That stuff's crazy. So
he can still be a benefit to Democrats that are running in that
case. So when you're saying can you use
a Republican that's never going to vote for mega or something
you absolutely can. You just have to be strategic when you do
this to make sure that it's not emboldening the other party and
helping your party and you winning cuz winning is winning. That's
it. It's the end of the day. Totally everybody would agree with
this. He just he just said he like everybody would say well if
it helps you win you should do that thing if it doesn't break
any of your values. He didn't add that part I did. Right?
Like platforming Hassan breaks none of these people's values.
It just doesn't. He just Dan just said nothing. I don't Come
on man. Come on Dan. Hey. So if you
Wait wait pause right there. If if Hassan and I promote Bernie
Sanders I'm the smaller That's why that's literally literally
Soy Pill's going to say so you totally support exactly what I
said. You're very much against Destiny. Got >> person.
We're promoting a candidate. How is this emboldening Hassan?
But oh Can I wait can I augment this argument a little bit? I
just Uh
Sorry. Is this funny when I explain what's happening and then
I watch Destiny get really antsy because he can also see what's
happening? It's very very very funny. Okay. >> The thing
that's nice about never Trump Republicans is there's no confusion
about what they are. They're Republican. The problem with people
like Hassan is that people think that they're like the same.
Like that's it. Like think about Liz Cheney and and Democrats.
There's no confusion that that Cheney was a Republican. There's
only one group of people who attacked Democrats over platforming
Liz Cheney and it was the tankies the Republicans.
Only the tankies attacked Democrats for campaigning with Liz
Cheney.
Only the tankies attacked Democrats. He's just saying something
totally
broken shattered away from reality again. Not even close to being
in this
Absolutely
insane that he just said that. Literally every single person
actual traditional media
roasted the [__] out of the Democrats for this. What
are we saying?
What are the [__] are you even attempting to say?
But Do you know what the more interesting question is than anything
they're actually talking about on this panel?
It's like will Destiny get smart enough people through like the
ways he's you know tried to network back in. Will he get smart
enough people to make him not sound like fast enough before people
start to catch on? Or people going to start to catch on like
to just how bad he is at doing his job at this point. He is terrible
at this. He is the worst he is a terrible debater at this point.
The only thing he does is yell over people and try to like gish
gallop try to spam out points without allowing for any response.
He is horrible at actually arguing. He is not arguing anything.
Like where where is the argument? He just lies. He just says
something that he is he has no idea what he's talking about.
He just said something I'm again total hunch probably somebody
in his chat said that.
Maybe. No not that one. That seems like something he'd make up.
That is his worldview failing. He does not care about politics.
He has no sincere engagement whatsoever and statements like that
just prove it that he needs other people feeding him arguments
constantly to ever look intelligent.
Yes they did. >> driven by the far left. It would only
because it was driven so much by the far >> vastly under
maybe online but you're vastly underestimating Hold on. Just
just just to be clear again I I I want to be clear with this.
Liz Cheney fundamentally votes against Democrats. Soy Pill this
isn't even we shouldn't even call this centrist. Only excuse
me. We shouldn't even call this centrist. It's it's just somebody
who spent the last year totally spitefully attacking anybody
who went and who was against him for his like crimes. He spent
the past year doing that. And then also trying to get laid going
to America tour events with Empath Chan. Okay that's been the
past year. He's had no political engagement so he has no idea
what he's talking about and he doesn't have anybody intelligent
to feed him arguments so he cannot look like a anymore. So it's
just him being like high coming on these panels and spewing out
like I would say talking points but they're not prepared. It's
just like a it's a low IQ stream of consciousness vomit of garbage
that is sort of made to look a little bit better because he knows
how to essentially mechanically argue things. Like he's been
mechanically arguing things. He knows when to cut people off.
He knows when he's lost a point he needs to spiral or sorry a
pivot away. He knows all of these things still but in terms of
his memories his like understanding of the arguments to make
his understanding of events that have gone down there's nothing
there and he's like brain
It's very it's crazy to watch. But Hold Hold on. Hold on. He
was going to be on the J6 on the January 6th commission. She's
like she's not I need you to acknowledge this. Soy Pill I need
you to acknowledge this. We weren't pretending that Liz Cheney
was a Democrat. Yeah. And and I I just pretending to like Bernie
Sanders or No this is way different HLA729 because he used to
have a little a lot of really smart people who would send him
arguments. He had a lot of really smart people who would come
and argue with him and he could sharpen those arguments before
he took really solid positions. Or he could watch other people
argue on his stream and take their positions. Right? Now he's
lost all of that. None of that happens anymore. So it's all like
falling apart. He just makes horrible argument after horrible
argument after horrible argument. Hold on let me back it up.
Soy Pill Soy Pill hold on. Soy Pill hold
You telling me that
you think centrist hate
Liz Cheney? No I need you to acknowledge this. Soy Pill
We weren't pretending that Liz Cheney was a Democrat. Do you
think Destiny is dumb? I feel like all this comes from laziness
and spite. I No I don't think he's dumb. I would love to say
like he he sounds very dumb but yes it is laziness. As a chief
thing it's laziness and it's
it's that he can't stop thinking about like other stuff. He can't
be stop being angry about other stuff and he just has a very
low engagement with the topic.
Right? He's he's good like there is a skill to taking multiple
arguments in like arranging them in your head building out some
way you think about it and then being able to argue those points
fluidly. There's a skill to that. I don't know if he has it anymore.
It does seem it does seem like he's sort of I I've just no seen
no evidence of it from before. That's the sad thing. I feel like
I would see but I guess I don't watch. Maybe there's evidence
of it still. He used to be able to do something like this that
was fairly effective.
But I it's
it seems to be gone in the content I watch. Like he I'm not joking
when I tell you outside of him just doing the tone indicators
he got rolled by Taylor Lorenz badly.
It's just the tone indication is the only thing that happens
that makes it look appear otherwise. Right? He got rolled by
Taylor Lorenz multiple
Yeah. And And I just want
that You that They're not Wait. You that I They don't to No No
to No to the the charm.
Soy Pill. Yep. Liz Cheney did more to help or to fight against
Trump than Kyle Kulinski did. She did more to fight against Trump
than Hassan did. She did more
Really? You think you think net votes Liz Cheney did more? Who
Who did Liz Cheney prevent from voting on the Republican side?
Nobody. And who did she get to vote on the Democrat side? Nobody.
Kyle Kulinski did
Kamala Harris pro-Kamala Harris propaganda. What the [__]
are we talking about? to fight against Trump than any of the
lefties who attacked her. Right? You understand that at a fundamental
level, correct?
Does Wek believe that Kyle Kulinski is a lefty who attacked Kamala
consistently going through the election? Does he believe that?
That seems insane to me that he would believe that. It's very
clear to me that Hasan and his audience probably won't do this
in any but you can do this in other races where you agree with
their picks. Why not do that? That's Well, one of the reasons
is then you tie yourself it it's the same reason you don't hang
around someone with leprosy.
You might get leprosy. And look at the way that they're attacking
him, thankfully, on CNN, MSM, like the the Fox News, all these
channels, mainstream media, like anyone who's going to be working
with Hasan is going to catch leprosy, right? So, they're going
to be able to effectively tie you and whatever cause that you
want to win.
This person shared
of his friends, his wife, his buddies with multiple people without
their consent. You know about it. You are perfectly happy being
tied to him. I don't understand. Hasan is way more popular. Hasan
is a way more likable person in general.
>> He's never done anything on this level before ever.
He docks his people. He is totally He docks his people not, by
the way, in any political sense, just people who have like essentially
been angry about his crimes. That's literally the the bar here.
People who are disappointed in him for his crimes. That's the
bar.
How in the world are you going to make the argument that Hasan
is going to get you tarred and feathered as a politician and
then sit here and do panels with Destiny? Maybe Maybe he's going
to But then you would have to say, "Oh, that same thing applies
to Destiny. Destiny should never associate with mainstream politicians,
right?"
That's That's got to be the line. If Wek is going to attempt
to apply the standard, that has to be the line, no? Not going
to be effective.
>> you think that's more poison than winning his audience
over? Like I if I saw data on that >> think we can win
his audience over in any real way. But when are you when are
you winning his audience over? I don't >> for candidates
that I want them to vote >> Yeah, but they're going to
do that anyway. They're voting for candidates they want to vote
for. It's only the candidates they want to vote for.
Yes. There are There are many candidates that Soy Pill wants
elected and Hasan also wants elected. And Soy Pill is saying,
"I think I will work with Hasan to get those candidates elected."
Yes. Thank you. You understand, guys. You do understand. They're
not They're never voting for candidates you want to vote for.
They're voting for candidates that they want to vote for. And
sometimes I And sometimes I want to vote for those candidates
and I'm willing to combine with leftists >> but you're
not winning them over to your side at that point. They're not
coming to you. They're free riders. I think when we're talking
about politicians, it is just
not my
it's not my position to say thing to to to know what is going
to be the most electorally optimal thing to do. Abdul El-Sayed
clearly thinks that working with Hasan is going to be electorally
optimal for him to do. He It is electorally optimal because I
don't think he had a shot without some radical action and that's
a radical action he could take, right? I think probably if he
just like kind of runs a standard campaign, breaks no mold, he's
just going to get [__] on. So, he needs to take some
radical steps and he needs to take risks. That's what he's doing.
That's why he's campaigning with Hasan. The standard If a if
a bog standard Democrat was doing incredibly well in the Michigan
primary,
they wouldn't talk to Hasan. That would be too big a risk.
How hard is it to understand that the El-Sayed guy just wanted
the big buzz around his campaign for this move. He wanted to
take a risk. Yes, it could work against him, but he wants to
take the risk. He clearly does or he wouldn't be doing it, right?
Well, he's in distant third. I think it was his only option.
Is is he was like, "I got to do something here cuz otherwise
I'm going to get [__] crushed." >> "Let's see
if the lefties actually vote." Because I if I was a political
No, he's trying to build any buzz he can. He's trying to get
in the media
Right? He's trying to get in the media cycle. That's what he's
trying to do. It's not going to be do the lefties actually vote.
The lefties would have been all of his base of support. The lefties
would have been voting for him already. They're trying to get
big names around him so that he could get in the media cycle,
so he get in the new cycle and be talked about. That's what he
wants. That's what he needs.
consultant if I was a political consultant, I would not recommend
appearing with Hasan. I'd recommend if you had appeared with
Hasan in the past, you take the Mom Dani strategy and you disavow
on stage if you're asked Keep moving. But So, I agree I'll go
ahead. Go ahead,
>> Go on, please. whenever we're talking about influence
I like I like the Mom Dani strategy. I disavow everything my
wife has ever said. That's the Mom Dani strategy. Working out
real well for him, by the way. Tons of people stopped calling
him anti-Semite.
Tons of people have stopped saying he's like he supports Hamas.
Definitely. What a great decision for him.
By the way, still love Mom Dani, just laughing at how the throat
clears never seem to do anything for those people either. Hey,
no, I don't support Hamas. Yeah, too bad. We're going to print
it constantly. Oh, look, your wife said some stuff. I DISAVOW
MY WIFE.
YEAH, I STILL THINK HE SUPPORTS HAMAS, >> WHICH is presume
I mean, I hate that term, but that's what that's what we're trying
to do. We're trying to influence people to have different political
And we don't want the politicians to sully themselves by I know
that he didn't actually disavow Hasan. It's not important for
me to point out, to be honest. Everybody knows that. associating
with Hasan.
I mean, if we just accept that this is only a one-way street,
then then we're screwed. We're screwed no matter what. If it's
only a one-way street, he's going to continue getting more and
more support, more and more voters, turning more and more people
off of politics until the country's dead. And I just refuse to
live in that reality. But that assumes he's one-way street is
when he engages with you, he's only converting from you. You
can't convert from him. He's not going to have an adversarial
conversation with you. He's just going to be there to slop up
your audience and then when he gets him on his platform,
he's going to try to con- Also, he's not going to grow infinitely.
He's not like
a game of snake where he just keeps growing and growing. There
he's been Just Every time I watch this person, it's very funny.
I'm not even I'm not hating, by the way, even though I totally
disagree with everything they're saying. They're just very funny
to >> like a
a game of [laughter] snake where Sorry. Just they're doing this
a lot all the time. And like at seemingly random times. So, it's
it's very funny to me. >> keeps growing and growing. There
he's been where he's been. There it sounds like it looks like,
"Dan, are you a What are you saying? I have no idea what you're
saying, Dan." capturing, unfortunately, or fortunately, depending
on your view, like what a lot of people are thinking about Israel.
No. No. Most people are probably thinking about the price of
gas. Most people are thinking about the price of rent. They're
thinking about Why Why is rent going up? Why is price of gas
going up?
Oh. [laughter]
That just sounds like Israel with extra steps right there. their
day-to-day lives. Most people don't give a [__] about
Israel. That's it. Now, a lot of lefties like to bring it to
that and say, "Oh, but the ultimate cause, it's It's okay. They
the Bibi he sat down with Trump and he made him get this war."
It's a privilege. We just read the article on it today.
Oh, bro, you can't make it up, man. >> point. Yeah, it
is. Most people don't know what the [__] going on.
You think the Israel Oh, no, give it to Give it to Hold on. Give
it to Destiny. Give it to Destiny. I I would say I I would disagree
with that. I I think that people do care about Israel, but I
think that there's another thing that hurts us because it inhibits
our ability to have a conversation about it. Like it sounded
Guys, you can't If somebody's like really upset because they
watched this like this um like teenager and her father walking
through the streets of Beirut and she's screaming, "Daddy, Daddy,
what's happening?" And they were upset by that. Well, that's
like if you if you feel empathy to that, that's really preventing
us from having a real conversation on this. Those people need
to shut the [__] up and understand that that's not
a real conversation. You can't center the conversation on Israel's
war crimes and how they're destroying Beirut and trying to ethically
cleanse
You can't talk about that cuz that's unreasonable. That makes
it seem like like supporting Israel or Israel itself is evil.
Like Like if you watch this if you watch these videos, right?
If you watch this and you feel an emotion, that's like really
preventing us from having the actual conversation about what
Israel's actually doing wrong. their civilians who were murdered
by the Israeli military using American weapons and American tax
dollars to do it. Stop the ceasefire
that the American president happily announced to the great relief
of the American people. All of it stopped by Operation Eternal
Darkness targeting civilians. But if you were a civilian on the
ground in Beirut, what would it look like? Well, we have this
video. This is a little Lebanese girl walking out on a sunny
day with her father, Operation Eternal Darkness.
That's for sure.
Wow. Sure.
Who's Who's the Who are the people bringing eternal darkness?
Guys, you just need to have the conversation the way Destiny
does, okay? You need to have the conversation the way the guy
who
advocated for the status quo, not making any moves at all. Like
who consistently tried to to denigrate and bring down the people
who were ringing the alarm bell on this. That's the guy you have
to listen to cuz he's the one who's the authority in the conversation.
Actually, toss yourself off of a three-step set of stairs cuz
you should feel a big boo-boo cuz I would never ever want to
physically hurt somebody.
And we don't advocate anything like that on the stream, okay?
Fantastic. We saved it. We saved it. We saved it. We saved it.
from her speeches. The Kamala Harris had a decent position on
it that we should have been pushing for more concessions from
Israel, that we needed a ceasefire in Gaza
as soon as possible. Like these were
You need a ceasefire in Gaza as soon as possible because Israel
honor ceasefires. It's That's the problem. Is unfortunately,
they have made anathema every honest conversation about Israel
for years and they're doing it again.
Destiny is doing it again. He is making it anathema to actually
talk about Israel the way you should. Oh, it's just really crazy
to say they're like evil and they're just causing destruction
and they're they're like ethnically cleansing another country.
No, it's not. This is objectively like evil at this They're they're
totally with the rest of the planet collectively for their own
ends and it needs to be talked about in these terms and you are
going to once again say like we really need a two-state solution
and we should have called for a ceasefire in Gaza. Bro, get on
board. Get on side. Figure out where the conversation is cuz
you're still missing it, okay? Maybe take a little more than
an hour or two to look into the issue. All right? Please, for
the love of God. They got mad at Kamala when she said we should
have a ceasefire. Not enough. I You you could say it, well, that's
better than nothing, but it is not enough and you're going to
consistently say, "Oh, no, you have to have the conversation
the way we're allowing you to." Shut up. No, you are all wrong.
You ceded the ability to set the table in this conversation when
you were totally wrong about Gaza, okay? And you don't get to
say anymore. You don't get to say not even the mainstream Dems
get to say anymore. And if you want to keep whining about it,
you want to keep about it, then lose another
good positions to take. But now to J.D. Vance who's planting
stories in the New York Times as we speak that make him look
like the anti-war candidate, the only sane Republican in the
room.
Is Destiny even aware of this article? Did Destiny read this
article? Does he know what's going on? Does he have any idea?
Doubt it. Oh, if our anti-Israel segment is going to be captured
by people like Hasan who would see Israel literally invaded and
destroyed as a country. Like that is his end goal. He's tweeted
it multiple times. Well, now in order to have the conversation
about oh, are you anti-Israel? It's are you anti-Israel and We
see those tweets about wanting Israel destroyed. I just I like
I I don't trust it. I don't trust Destiny on this. Not that I
think Hasan couldn't tweet that when he's very upset something
like that Lebanon video we just watched cuz hey, we're all a
little emotional when we watch like this. People on this panel
could never understand being emotional about things like this,
but we are, okay? So, I sort of understand how some people could
feel that way sometimes, but you're going to have to show me
him advocating for that in any serious way which I know he hasn't
cuz I know if he had, you would bring it up. No, you have to
wanted the destruction of the entire country. So, like I agree
that like the Democratic voter base has moved to having a negative
opinion of Israel. I think over I think a majority at this point
for sure, but that doesn't mean that it's the same as like I
want to destroy Israel like Hasan and and his ilk do which I
but I think they have like a monopoly on those talking points
right now, unfortunately.
Again, every time you every time you start you start to tone
police on the Israel question beyond saying like obviously we're
not going to nuke Israel which again, I don't think Hasan's ever
actually advocated for, right?
I don't think so. Every time you tone police on it, you are trying
to uphold the status quo that's untenable.
I'm sorry, you are. You are every single time. So, when we watch
videos like this, when we watch all the war crimes Israel's doing
constantly constantly doing, okay?
It gets hard to contain how upset you are. I can this person
has platform of people that would agree with me. I'm going to
capitalize on that. If you bring up the worst things Hasan has
said, I'm going to disavow those and distance myself from those
and Mondaire already did this and still was able to utilize Hasan's
audience. Why is that bad or is it bad? You can't utilize Hasan's
audience. You're saying something disingenuous. >> you
mean? Clearly do you Mondaire did not No arguments. Just no no
arguments at all. Why do all these political consultants seem
to think that they can? Why are these politicians going on at
all? Why do so many political consultants seem to disagree with
you, Dan? Are you just way better Should you just be running
like a consultancy group cuz you're you've got a way better strategy
than these people? I I just I don't get it. I get a single voter
from the Hasan audience like >> Every single one of Wait,
wait, do you think they would have voted for Mondaire Hasan not
said anything? >> Yeah, well, they're going to be Cuomo
voters. Give me give me a break. Hasan did nothing. They weren't
going to get the opportunity to vote for Mondaire unless Hasan
endorsed him. Well, I don't know. I It's hard to say. I didn't
follow enough of the campaign, but I do know Hasan came in was
like, "Oh, we love this guy. Go and get the word word out on
this on this Mondaire guy." Without him when so, when he was
low like 20% in the polls,
if if that makes a difference and he loses the primary, Mondaire
can't run in the general as an independent. At 3%, sorry, at
3% polling.
At 3% polling, sorry.
Hasan can't roll in like I don't know if Mondaire wins. Sorry,
that's all I want to say. I don't know if Mondaire wins that
primary without Hasan there. Like 3%?
That's a lot, no?
Hasan was just someone who popped in to claim credit. I'm pretty
sure he started trying to blow Mondaire up when Mondaire was
not a
And then he explicitly tried to get his name out there with and
it's New York City, so that is a place Hasan would have clout.
Probably one of the bases of power of Hasan [__]
no?
New York City, California, these places that are extremely far
left leaning. You would think. I don't know why you'd say he
only popped in to claim credit. Seems a little weird, but I Well,
maybe they wouldn't have voted at all. They were like, "Oh, Mondaire's
not good enough, right? Like he's he's he's going to capitulate
to liberals." Are you saying that with a straight
Yeah, yeah. I'm saying that So, what what what if Hasan didn't
endorse then maybe they wouldn't even like support him at all,
right? Yeah, so what what what give me numbers or odds there.
So, let's say that Hasan had a thousand voting people in New
York, okay? And out of those thousand voting
voters in New York, how many of them you think would not vote
for Mondaire if Hasan didn't come out? Yeah. Uh They're they're
going to be Cuomo voters. I I I'll say in my mind this might
be an overestimate. I bet he doubled the support that from his
audience by bringing attention to him. He doubled So, they were
going to be Cuomo voters. Doubled the support from Hasan's audience.
No, I understand what you mean, but wow.
You're saying that without Hasan
endorsing Mondaire,
Cuomo had a chance, basically.
I I don't [snorts] know how slim the margins were. I'm saying
I I think the thing is is a what I I would assume this is the
difference,
That there might have been more than one progressive candidate
to start out the primary in the New York mayoral race,
Without Hasan, perhaps they failed to coalesce around one specific
candidate.
Right? Like he ups the media credibility the the media time of
this one specific
And in effect sort of crowns them and then the progressives coalesce
around that one person, right? So, like basically progressives
being able to coalesce around one candidate allows them to win
the primary which allows them to actually be to vote for Mondaire
in the general. But I don't even know that these people
like where the endorsement came and what was going on. I think
that Hasan's audience is going to in mass be more supportive
of a guy that Hasan endorses than if he doesn't endorse or drives
apathy about that candidate, right? Okay. Well, I mean, maybe.
Oh.
Oh, okay. Interesting.
Very interesting. I mean, it does help coalescing coalescing
does help in terms of media viability, right? So, but it wouldn't
be as big a deal, I guess, in the final choices. I'm sure every
single Hasan voter who's going out to vote would have put Mondaire
higher than some of the liberal candidates. Sure. Uh so, it's
I I it seems like Mondaire was able to capitalize off of Hasan's
audience. And also avoid all the worst associations because once
you know, Cuomo tried to smear him on this, but then once he
gets away from that, it's like, "Okay, well, now I'm just going
to distance myself. I'm not inviting him to the upstairs after
party. Like I don't want to associate with this person and the
worst things they said, but I'm able
Didn't I I don't remember if he got into the upstairs after party.
It's not a big deal. I just remember him hanging out with Medhi
Hasan and
and all of the other big left influencers. So, I I don't know
if he got in there or not. I He did. People are saying he did.
I assume where Medhi Hasan was is the big influencer party.
Cuz Medhi Hasan and a bunch of these other guys are like not
the people,
Am I crazy?
We'll take the good things about this and help make me help it
me win, right? Didn't he Didn't he explicitly Can I ask a tangential
Well, hold on. Destiny first, then Ryan. Didn't Didn't Mondaire
have to explicitly disavow Yeah, he disavowed him on stage. At
the debate.
I'm curious why we think it's They're all they're all saying
this. It's very
that he he did the same thing Ro Khanna did, right? It's Is it
not the same thing Ro Khanna did?
Can somebody just send me the clip? Send me the clip so we can
actually watch it cuz I assume it's basically the same thing
Ro Khanna did. Oh, of course I disavow that language, but there's
a lot of things there that like I agree with or you know, this
guy helped me, something along these lines, but It's cool to
work with like So, he's telling you that I didn't Didn't Mondaire
have to explicitly disavow Yeah, he disavowed him on stage. At
the debate. I'm curious why we think it's So, he said yeah. So,
he said yeah. >> cool to work with like Mondaire and other
DSA people because the DSA explicitly says like that they want
to take over the Democratic Party and make it a socialist institution.
Like that's not a secret. In the case of Mondaire, it's because
the other option was grandma killer Cuomo, okay? Um he was so
radioactive that he was a worse option than the DSA >> options
were Republican. Oh, you telling me that a harasser
assaulter is is like some total totally degenerate past is like
radioactive too radioactive to align with politically? No way.
I didn't know I didn't know I didn't know Wick held this position.
That's crazy. Yeah. Well, but also and also wait wait wait, but
also in terms of what's being said there though, keep in mind
like what's going on. This is another difference is that if somehow
AOC or Mondaire even doesn't have a Assume Mondaire wins the
the the Democratic presidential primary, right? I'm pretty sure
like I would hope like 90 to 95% only the Muslim thing would
be a question I guess for some people. But like 90 to 95% of
Democrats are voting for Mondani. Whereas if Newsom wins the
nomination, right? What is that Half half of the Hassan hardcore
people are dropping off, maybe more. How many Hassan hardcore
people do we think there are? I'm curious. Like voters in the
United States? Yeah, like I think I think it's a five-figure
number or lower. I think it's a low amount of numbers or the
number of people it's low, but the problem is by So Desi said
the hardcore people are all the people in the chat. Right? If
you think only 10,000 people show up to Hassan's stream to chat,
I don't know what to tell you. You're mathematically illiterate.
You know what I'm saying? So I I just there's 10,000 Hassan voters
capturing so much of the conversation, it poisons
other conversations we could be having. So for instance, I don't
think that the Israel and Palestine was not an issue that was
of such high salience that I think it could could have cost us
the election in 2024, but I think that the obsession with the
conversations around Israel-Palestine
cost us 2024, if that makes sense. Like Hassan's audience being
so obsessed and being so online and like that or or not even
just Hassan's audience, but just that that the obsession with
that kind The obsession The obsession with trying to stop things
like what's going on in Lebanon right now. It's just totally
deranged to have this obsession with using your tax dollars to
kill a bunch of brown people in the Middle East. It's just obsessed
and deranged and crazy.
You You need to unfold. You need to unfold what you mean. I Like
every single time they would just refuse to unfold it. conversation
I don't really think that that cost us 2024 in any way, shape
or form. >> I I understand that, but what I'm saying is
that the fact that there were two things that you could I I understand
that, but let me cook. I'll I'll explain why you have to disavow
and and disassociate from Hassan right now, even though I don't
say that. Listen. These people are obsessed with the idea of
like human rights in other countries and our inability to violate
them. They're obsessed with it.
It's crazy. >> talk about if you were a Democrat in 2024.
You could either talk about whatever the Republicans want you
to talk about, which is trans people, or you're like getting
from the left by Israel-Palestine, and that's it. You It's like
no time where you can ever message on your own message because
everything is constantly being either a response to crazy I thought
Where Where are like politicians getting asked about Israel-Palestine
consistently? You have like one Breaking Points interview with
Krystal Ball. Where in the world are are politicians consistently
getting pressed in 2024 on the Israel-Palestine issue? This is
You guys make fun of Hassan's audience for being terminally online.
Holy hell. Where in the world was this a real-world conversation?
Where was anybody The whole problem people have is that it wasn't
being talked about. Is that it was essentially being swept under
the rug. That's why the lefties got so deranged about it. Because
when when a bunch of kids get killed, they go IDF allegedly,
you know, sorry. Children
harmed in
Gaza beach bombing.
That's That's like the the headline you get. It's like this.
That's why people get mad.
But no No serious political leader No Nowhere in traditional
media does this topic come up. It took By the way, it took people
driving it here for it to become even a thing now. The morally
correct decision was to make this a problem in 2024. Failing
that, make it a problem now. the Republicans are saying or it's
more Israel-Palestine from the far left. And I feel like the
opportunity cost of never getting to have like a media apparatus
that allows you to say things and message on things and do whatever
is just It's agonizing.
Yeah. No, I agree. I mean, I think that that's something that
we should, you know, Soy Pill's literally laughing right now.
He's laughing to himself.
Not pushing back. No, I agree. I mean, I think that that's something
that we should, you know, work to build and that's why I'm, you
know, happy to appear on your thing tomorrow where we're going
to be talking about raising money to help elect Democrats. Hell
So I mean, I think that that's absolutely a thing that needs
to be done. But [snorts] I just I sent
I think if somebody's going to bring these people back from the
brink. I know I keep reiterating this, but it's going to if if
unless we think it is totally impossible
to win back people who are nihilistic anti-politics
from the brink, then we should be trying. We should be trying
to do it.
>> No, you can't bring them back because Hassan and these
other people have intentionally designed their platform so that
that cannot happen. If this was just an ideological battle in
a vacuum, sure, but Hassan will not expose his audience to critical
confrontation. The same way that all of MAGA works right now.
This is explicitly and specifically how these audiences are designed.
That's the issue. I don't know What happened when Soy Pill What
happened when Soy Pill was like, "Hey Desi, aren't you doxxing
people like pretty consistently?" What happened when Soy Pill
did that? There's a lot of critical engagement with that, wasn't
there? I was [laughter] going to say. Can I Can I respond to
that? Before you respond, hold on. Let Dan get his Okay, well
then I'm going to have to respond to both of them. Yeah, you
can. That that's Also, just to be clear,
I assume Or Are we thinking that Gavin Newsom goes on Hassan's
broadcast and says nothing bad? Is that what we think
That That Gavin Newsom would go on Hassan's broadcast and he
wouldn't go, "You know, I want to talk about some of the things
you've been saying." Right? Wouldn't Wouldn't he do that? Wouldn't
he go on and like want to disassociate in some ways like over
those things?
Hassan's inviting up people who disagree all the time.
I don't Call me crazy. Is Adam Mockler not somebody who disagrees
with Hassan
And who's like actually really really well suited to debate?
Is Is Adam Mockler not just a more engaged, higher work ethic,
more intelligent, less
predator version of Destiny? Isn't that like Isn't he just better
than Destiny in every way except the degenerate lying scumbag
ways?
So he He brought Adam Mockler on. What was the problem there?
How is he not exposing his audience to somebody who will critique
him? Was he not explicitly exposing his audience to somebody
who would critique him there?
I just I don't understand. This is just another lie. This is
yet another lie.
That's the way it will be fair. That'll be fine. It's not worth
going after them because the amount of concessions you would
have to give to get one Hassan voter would cost you 20 other
voters that would be normal. And that's That's That's why That's
why Is it possible to get Hassan voters? I don't believe he has
this like lock box on his viewership or whatever. This is how
the media environment has worked for the past like five years.
It's locking down your audience and your algorithm as much as
possible. How many large figures, Emma Vigeland, Ryan Grim, Sam
Seder, Taylor Lorenz, all of these weirdo far left probably Media
Son, will literally tell you with a straight face that Hassan
was not shocking his dog on stream. I don't even know most people
here even even know or believe it think that that's just a meme,
but it was true. This is like the most like don't believe what's
in front of your eyes ever in order to carry talking point. If
the majority of his audience and the majority of the people on
the far left over there can sell you that lie,
I'm so far away. God. I like literally every single time. There
are so many moments where I could have walked away and been gone
for like 5 minutes and not had to pause and nothing contentious
would have been said and it would have been fine. And every single
time I've walked away for two goddamn seconds, immediately something
totally insane and objectionable gets said and I have to come
back.
It's actually wild. It's crazy.
Okay, I have to go back probably like 10, 15 seconds. I went
to the bathroom
and I swear to God, I'm not even
not even taking a piss yet before he says something totally insane.
the lock box on his viewership or whatever. This is how the media
environment has worked for the past like five years. It's locking
down your audience and your algorithm as much as possible. How
Does she just go bolting through your place yelling to see how
No, I do that when I'm coming back to my desk doing DKed that
I'm like not muted. I'm like not muted. I am actually far away
from my desk, so I do it coming back to my desk so you can hear
it. many large figures, Emma Vigeland, Ryan Grim, Sam Seder,
Taylor Lorenz, all of these weirdo far left probably Media Son,
will literally tell you with a straight face that Hassan was
not shocking his dog on stream. I don't even know most Mehdi
Hasan and Krystal Ball and Kyle KULINSKI DON'T GIVE A [__]
ABOUT KAYA BECAUSE THEY GOT BIGGER PROBLEMS.
NONE OF THEM THEY PROBABLY DON'T EVEN THEY MIGHT NOT EVEN KNOW
THAT LIKE IF THEY KNOW, they just don't care. They think it's
irrelevant. That none of them give a Literally zero of them give
a None of them care because they're actual political actors.
Holy [__]
This guy's acting like like Mehdi Hasan has gone on The Nation
and made multiple pieces about how it's totally crazy to say
Hassan shocked
Are you out of your
This is the most embarrassing point made yet on this panel. How
many of these people like Ryan Grim and Mehdi Hasan No, they
kill about They care about They kill about You can see where
I'm going. They care about kids getting killed in Israel right
now, not Kaya getting trained with a shock collar. Not Kaya even
Even in the worst case, Kaya being shocked to stay in place for
hours. They They don't care cuz it turns out that lots of worse
things are happening in the world that they do care about and
do report about and are respected for covering. How many people
respect somebody who spent a significant amount of time covering
Kaya? And I say that as somebody who spent a significant amount
of time covering Kaya. It's so disconnected from any normal
conversation grounded in reality. It's so disconnected. So far
away. It's like gone. It's all the way gone.
Most people here even even know or believe it think that that's
just a meme, but it was true. This is like the most like don't
believe what's in front of your eyes ever in order to carry talking
point. If the majority of his audience and the majority of the
people that follow him over there can sell you that lie, how
can we pretend that this is an audience that's readily converted
into something like I Soy Pill, you watch The Majority Report.
Soy Pill, you watch The Majority Report, you watch Emma Vigeland,
you watch uh Krystal Ball, all of these people. Did they spend
a significant amount of time trying to convince you that Hasan
didn't shock his dog?
Or did they basically laugh and go, "This seems pretty insane.
I can't believe people care about this."
Which by the way, you could say, "They don't want to talk about
it." And that shows some bias. I'll give you that. But they're
not trying to sit here and and like gaslight people. By the way,
I went through all those frames and I'm like, "I can't see that
she's definitely wearing the shock collar." But I didn't say
anybody was wrong for thinking that. I said it looks bad. I knew
that. that they all view as Yes, and just a real quick before
you respond before you before you But just totally deranged thinking
like somebody like Medhi Hasan would go and
would go and defend the Kaya thing, Kayagate. That's wild. Before
you respond, let me piggyback off this and I do want to give
it to Marlo because she's being very polite, right? Um Wait,
wait, hold on. Also, cuz this is like a 7 v 2 panel. So, I feel
like Ryan and Soy Pill will have to I understand. They'll
Guys, I know this seems like a cult humiliation ritual where
we're trying to all pile on these guys and losing again, by the
way.
Give them a chance to talk. Come on, give them a chance to talk.
Get their chance. Let me moderate my WHAT WHAT IF RYAN GRIM TOLD
YOU, TRIED TO GASLIGHT YOU, AND PRETEND that Hasan didn't shock
his dog? Meanwhile, Ryan Grim over the past year building up
a platform like plus like 80% revenue on Drop Site News, subscription
only $100 subscription, I believe, subscription only service,
right? That you don't even have to subscribe for to read
because people just appreciate his reporting that much. He's
like, "Who the [__] is Kaya? Wait, what? Who Wait,
there's a
Is Kaya a person?
Oh, it's Hasan's dog. Oh, I don't care. Did you know that Did
you know that Israel just blew up a whole like multiple lines
of houses with time detonations in the Gaza Strip? They're trying
to flatten that entire place so nobody can move back. Oh, you
don't want to talk about that? You want to talk about Hasan's
dog? Oh. Well, I can see where your priorities are. Very cool.
panel Destiny Well, you're not moderating right now. You're attacking
them. You're participating. Yeah, for sure. Yeah. >> I
am doing both. I am wearing two hats. Well, one hood, one hat.
You're not doing both. You have not even I've not seen him attempt
to moderate at all other than give people an order that they're
going in. He's not attempted to resolve or ask like, "Hey, what
How do we know this?" He's not actually clarified anything for
anyone. He's not moderating whatsoever. Sure. I think But the
point that I was making, I've already
conceded. I don't think that you're winning over the people that
watch Hasan multiple hours a day every day. It's like trying
to get someone out of the Fox News, you know, where it's burned
into the corner of the screen type
I think a lot of people have a positive opinion of Hasan that
get him somewhat passively, that consume him somewhat regularly,
that consider themselves democratic socialist because they hear
him talk passionately about Israel, about Medicare for All, and
about a jobs guarantee. I got to weigh I way overshot I saw around
2,000 viewers for that stream. But still, far more than what
I okay? Or whatever. And I think yeah, those people are winnable.
And I'm sorry I keep repeating myself on that point. But if we
think that the voters are unamenable to reason, then I don't
even see the point in being a liberal. Like if we don't
>> Yes, Ryan, take the black pill with me. We're going
down with the ship even though we're pretty sure the ship is
broken, okay? We're going down with the ship, but the ship don't
work no more. Or sorry, we know, okay? We know there's no way
off. We know we know, but we're just going down with it, okay?
That doesn't require quite as much Do you think that Dylan fundamentally
made a mistake by going and promoting pro-Ukraine talking points
on a fundamentally anti-war panel that was not really talking
about Ukraine because Hasan was on it? No, but Dylan is one of
the few people who is like so crystal clear on his position on
everything that like I I think that he's always trustworthy to
be in those environments. I would never see him bend over backwards
on anything to defend any of these other people. And we're cool
with the, you know, slightly adversarial but mostly friendly
panel that was last year with Tarlov and Hasan and Tim Miller
and a couple other
I was okay because it was an okay start, but I mean like people
just have to recognize it for what it is. I don't Like if people
knew what Hasan was, I wouldn't care how many panels they have
cuz I imagine it would it would be Just We we we cannot construct
a solid ought, right? Every time This is This is the every conversation
with Destiny now.
you're fine with that crooked con panel that would like you you
ought not like, you know, attack Hasan the whole time. It could
be mostly, "Well, you know, I'm kind of fine cuz it's like this
and it would be fine if everybody I The only ought is you have
to tell everybody that Hasan is a liar, he is a scumbag, he is
anti-democratic,
he will totally sell America out to its enemies, he will immediately
try to over any democratic candidate he can automatically,
right? If you're willing to talk about Hasan this way all the
time and never waver, then I don't have to call you out. Then
I don't have to attack you. Okay, well, that seems pretty reasonable.
Cool. generally adversary most of the time, but it's when these
people pretend that Hasan is just a guy who wants single-payer
healthcare and strong social equality or whatever. Well, so I
agree with you like if you like to This is Soy Pill is going
to slowly come to the realization that Pisco did that there's
no good faith engagement you can have here. Like that this is
just set up like the exercise you think you're doing is not the
exercise being undertaken by any of these people. You think you're
talking about something to do with how you should form coalitions
politically, and this is other people trying to convince as many
other people as they can. This is a different group trying to
convince as many people as they can that Hasan is evil and you
need to like try to with them at any cost. You You have to do
that. That's the most important thing
Right? That's It's way different. That's what Pisco realized
eventually. Soy Pill is going to realize that eventually that
he's not even nobody engages with his arguments. Nobody engages
with when they're wrong. Nobody actually like admits that they
were wrong about
It's just Hasan is bad. That's really all they're engaging in
here. And
that there is if you are an honest thinker at all, you you don't
want to participate here. There's just no point. It's totally
pointless.
And I know [clears throat] this is like was a meme, but on the
PV panel when like all the people are like, "And I disavow Hasan
for his terrorist support, and I do this, and just so you know,
Hasan believes this, and now we can >> Like like unironically,
if people just did that before every conversation where percentually
you'd have the same support for a candidate, would that then
be
Be better.
Well, I I I don't I don't think it does it just doesn't work
that way. It depends on what we're saying.
>> Soy Pill just gave away, by the way, that would be totally
insane, right? If you you're you're Every time you see that on
any panel you
right? When somebody comes on, that's like the Adam Sosnick thing
a little
Right? Anybody comes on and they go, "Here's the reasons you
should never listen to this person." Poisoning the well, poisoning
the well, poisoning the well, poisoning the well. Like everybody
goes, "Oh, like you look really bad to me. You're not even making
the argument,
Like you're you're not making an argument. You're not talking
about the issue. You are trying to attack this person's character.
So, like there's no way to do that in a way that works. Like
I don't I But even though Soy Pill is like, "You are saying all
of these things. If people only realized who Hasan was, then
you could do it." And he goes, "Well, what if I did all this?"
Basically giving him what he wants. He goes, "Well, I don't know
about that." I disavow everything and now we're just going to
have a friendly conversation. That's not the message that you
would sell to people. And and these guys I don't disavow everything
if he's going to support a progressive candidate. Like I don't
disavow that part. Look at them on the other side. Look at how
they view people in the liberal camp. If you had a single association
with anybody that they deemed to be bad ever, no matter how combative
your association was, they'll always use that to every single
thing about you. Yeah, and don't you think this is more to the
fact that they're allergic to power and will shoot themselves
in the foot, but we can still capitalize on the power that they
can lend us when when they can? them using their platform to
exclusively try to capture from our audience as well in inoculating
their own audiences from ever being captured by us because they
constantly poison the well. They're not making excuses for us.
They're Why does that inoculation not work for Soy Pill?
Why is Soy Pill not inoculating his audience by talking about
how Hasan is bad, right?
Yeah, I mean, it is mirror posting again, but I'm just saying
like what is the what is the reasoning for why Soy Pill can't
do this and engage in the same thing, and then they both just
end up supporting a candidate? It's all totally fine. It's like
well, all all washed out in the end.
Why would this matter?
What power do these irrelevant Just you can engage I mean, you
If you want to just say like, "Oh, you all suck and nobody really
cares about you guys." And then you don't engage, you could do
that, but then we wouldn't have be having fun and having content.
So, I don't know. I don't really want to do that necessarily.
Oh, I hope somebody points this out to Soy Pill cuz Semaphore
just made the best counterpoint chat. I'mma pull it up right
now. I swear I've heard Destiny say he gets a ton of ex-Hasan
fans become a DGGers.
YES! OH MY GOD, THEY'RE in a they're in a echo chamber. They
can never escape. But also, I get a ton of emails from people
who used to be Hasan fans and how they they've switched over
to me because they never realized just how bad he was. Dude,
yes!
I didn't even think about that. Yeah, that is funny. Oh, that's
so funny, man.
That's that's super goofy.
Hutch says the same thing? Dude.
Oh, man, that is how you do this. You get the compilation of
those You get the compilation of those moments from Hutch and
Destiny. Oh yeah, there's this Hasan viewer who like talks to
me about how awesome it is that he's here now and all
Let's go.
Let's go. Wait, well, coalition partner, he's I mean, I know
people who went from Hasan's audience, but it's mostly that they
were Hasan and Destiny's fans, and then they just went with Destiny
when those two split, right? Comments on YouTube say it? Oh,
very interesting. >> person that's like worth working with.
We do have some overlap in belief. Meanwhile, he's saying that
all of the liberal beliefs are fake. They're just like it's just
here to it's the pressure valve to ease some of the tensions
while they try to distract from corporate issues. It's the Epstein
parties.
Well, it is the pressure valve for it it is that. You are excitedly
that. Why do you run away from the thing that you
You're like the way to to negotiate between the populace and
corporations and try to bridge that wealth gap, right? Try to
bring the wealth gap down. That's what you're supposed to be.
You should excitedly be that. Why do you take that that description,
which is obviously true? It is and by the way, because you won't
address any of the major issues, it is a managed decline. And
because you're now at the point where actually pointing out this
managed decline is now like tankieism.
I don't even know how you address it anymore. You basically have
to do propaganda openly.
But you should be that you are that thing. You are trying to
negotiate the wealth basically being used properly in your country
without reorganizing the entire economy. That's what you want
to do. That's your mission.
That's your whole point. THAT'S WHY YOU EXIST. TO MAKE TOAST.
WELL, how do you how do you square the circle with like and again,
I don't think this is bad. I think this is a good thing. Like
you you work with like CounterPoints, right? And like I'll work
with CounterPoints and this guy has clearly said he'd vote for
JD Vance in an election. He's not a Democrat. He's a devout Republican
and repeat the same thing. CounterPoints is a Republican. Everybody
knows where he stands. If he started showing up on my stream,
okay, with a with a two-two pretending he was a a gay liberal
or something and I knew he was lying, I don't think I'd have
the same conversations with him. But people know who CounterPoints
is. He's a Republican. He's he's open about that. But nobody
in my audience thinks that. They think he's a Republican. Like
the the the the this is what I'm saying was like there's this
moving target of like who's in the tent. It's like, okay, are
they going to support the general? And it's like, well, he's
not, right? >> target. It is not a moving target. It's
never been a moving target. You keep moving the target. >> It's
been a movie Oh my god. Just so we're clear, Soy Po's point the
whole time was as long as I do these throw clears, these like
upfront, you know, disavowals of Hasan, as long as I'm sufficiently,
you know, critical of Hasan,
then I can go on platforms with Hasan because my audience is
inoculated. And Destiny said, "No." the whole time, but that's
been Soy Po's point the whole time. And then when Destiny lays
it all out, it is just everything and Soy Po says, "Okay, well,
maybe he says, 'No, I don't want to appear with you anymore.'"
then he just doesn't appear with me anymore. But like we have
no other problems. So Soy Po has completely won the argument.
There is no escape hatch for Destiny. Soy Po has won the argument.
Destiny had a problem with him. Soy Po has basically shown that
Destiny's arguments are totally like they've totally failed against
Soy Po when he was when Destiny was originally critical of the
PP panel. midst of the midterms, you're someone who's been quite
outspoken. You have made several appearances on a show hosted
by socialist commentator Hasan [__] Some of your
fellow Democrats though have raised alarms about his views. Here
too, members of a left-leaning think tank. This is how they put
it. They wrote, quote, "No left-wing agitator is more influential
and extreme than Twitch streamer Hasan [__] He's
referred to ultra-Orthodox Jews inbred, employed anti-Semitic
dog whistles, bloodthirsty violent pig dog against an anti-Hamas
viewer of his stream, compared liberal Zionists to liberal Nazis
and said Hamas is a thousand times better than the Israeli state."
Now, Hasan [__] says some of his comments have been
taken out of context, but he largely stands by them. Do you have
any regrets about appearing on his show? None. And I would go
again, but I of course condemn those comments. I mean, I've described
Moody Morgan, thank you so much for the gifted sub. I appreciate
it. Thank you. Thank you. Hamas is a terrorist state and we need
to unequivocally condemn anti-Semitism. But Hasan [__]
was at the DNC in 2024 covering Vice President Harris. What should
the standard of the Democrats be? Should we not go on Theo Von?
Should we not go on Sean Ryan? Should we not go on Joe Rogan?
Should we just have these purity tests of canceling folks? The
lesson of the last election is we've got to be out there. We've
got to engage. It's a complex, messy, multiracial democracy.
I will defend my views, but the people who are saying don't engage
will cost us future elections. Do you run the risk of legitimizing
someone like Pretty much the point of this clip if you want to
pause it there. Okay. Sure. Like to me that was kind of the embodiment
of what That guy is totally sane-washing Hasan [__]
He's a really disgusting fellow, okay? Like to me that was kind
of the embodiment of what Destiny even or you guys were all saying,
which is like as long as he is able to condemn and and sufficiently
distance himself from the worst parts of this, but then utilize
the platform, like I I don't I I agree that this is somehow not
beneficial to him. Because that's not happening. He misunderstands
what everybody's asking for. Like the fact that he immediately
ran to compare Hasan [__] to Theo Von and Joe Rogan
like demonstrates his his lack of understanding of of what people
are even talking about. Like if if he went on to these platforms
to argue with Hasan [__] about substantial disagreements,
like do we expect him to go on with Joe Rogan and just be agreeing
the whole time that Probably created an But not No, but that
he's not going to go on Joe Rogan and have a conversation about
COVID. You you go on Joe Rogan not You're going on Joe Rogan
to court their voters.
I I think did did Destiny expect Kamala Harris to go on Joe Rogan
and go, "So, you endorsed Trump. Don't you think that's a little
problematic? Don't you think it's a little problematic you endorsed
Trump last year? Don't you think it's a little problematic the
way you talked about COVID vaccines? Don't you think that's like
a problem, Joe?" Yeah. Do Do you Do you want her to lose the
election harder? What the [__] is wrong with this
guy?
This guy's out of his goddamn mind.
He By the way, he's just trying to like make a point. This obviously
isn't even a good like she's the one going on. She's not going
to be the one disagreeing with with Joe Rogan. She's trying to
court Joe Rogan's audience. That's the whole point. But they're
going to go Like Destiny just totally inverted his own point.
Was that probably His point should be Well, it's probably difficult
for Ro Khanna to go on there and properly disavow Hasan Piker's,
you know, rhetoric because he's trying to court Hasan's audience.
That should be his point. He's so He's so spun around. He's so
confused, disoriented. He doesn't know which way he should argue.
You know, do we expect him to go on with Joe Rogan and just be
agreeing the whole time that
But not No, but that he's not going to go on Joe Rogan and have
a conversation about COVID. They're going to go on and he's going
to you know, I like speaking of like someone who's interacted
with Ro Khanna a lot. When he goes on adversarial platforms,
he's usually not arguing. He's like, "Where can we find common
ground? Where can we like push this forward? Like, hey Joe, like
you're frustrated with this. I'm frustrated with this." Like
he's not going to go on and argue with Dude, Destiny's been doing
that a lot recently. It's very funny. He actually did Soy Po
quite a bit, right?
Destiny just Destiny's He literally just said, "I'm not going
to educate you." Very leftist-coded, no? Like that's like the
2019th left 2019 leftist-coded playbook. "Well, if you don't
know, it's not my job to educate you." He's done that to Soy
Po at least three times now that I can recall in the past two
debates. "If you don't know, I'm not going to educate you." Very
cool. put yourself in a corner here by not conceding that you
would do this for Fuentes or Asmongold. I don't know why you
don't just bite the >> you don't agree with my position,
but I think fundamentally these audiences are completely different,
so. Okay. Yeah. I mean, I I I don't know. I I agree with Soy
Po here on the difference in the audience question. I know I
know people that watch Hasan regularly. Uh they are not tankies.
You should go watch his stream when he had a Houthi terrorist
That's bad. That These are bad This is bad stuff. You go look
at his chat and you can actually The Honestly, was it I'm trying
to think. I like I've kind of gotten off the point of the Houthi
terrorist thing being all that bad.
I Again, my my points about the Houthi stuff, the support for
the Houthis, came almost entirely from how he reacted to the
galaxy leader being captured and those people being captured.
I think cheering for that and celebrating that, even though it
is what you, you know, even if you were saying it's striking
a blow for Israel, I do think the idea of stri of stri striking
a blow against Israel, which that's debatable in the first place.
But even if you agreed on that, the idea of cheering for people
being kidnapped is just wrong to me. That's like my problem,
right? The people that you say that watch like Hasan regularly,
like are these people that are voting for a conservative? Like
if they were to stop watching Hasan, are they going to become
conservative? No. Probably not. Okay, but is there a chance in
watching Hasan that they're going to be moved so far that they
believe that like the Democratic and the Republican Party are
more or less the same and there's no point in engaging with the
elections outside of like the most radical primary wins ever?
Probably so. Yeah, there's a
Again, this this characterization, I don't know why they give
up this
I I honestly don't. I straight up don't get it at all. Like the
idea It is the idea that you can't say that you can't call a
spade a spade, a genocide a genocide, right? And be upset with
your politicians for supporting it while also admitting that
even though you're supporting this genocide, which Hasan didn't
do. I'm not even giving him this. But I think a lot of people
did. While they did support a genocide, while they were there
watching as Israel committed war crimes, letting it go,
they were going to be better than Donald Trump on all domestic
issues and that realistically on Gaza there's no way Trump was
going to be better. So, unfortunately, it's like you do at the
end of the day vote for the people who are going to help you
and you probably live to fight another day. There may be somewhere
where you eventually say like, "Hey, I need people who are going
to actually commit to doing something about this." I don't know
I don't know if it's if that's the way you go with Trump. I don't
know. I I I still mean no.
that that idea that you could say, "Well, you still vote blue
here at the end of the day, but obviously these people supported
genocide and I wanted them to make better decisions." I I feel
like that has to be allowed. That is fundamentally what democracy
is. Is you giving your real opinion, you putting your real voice
out and saying exactly what you think. You could argue that,
"Hey, everybody's got to fall in line and even rhetoric against
the current candidate is like problematic." But then you're just
arguing for MAGA. You're arguing to let all these things go.
You're arguing for the party that now at this point literally
Trump is going against every priority they had because they've
been letting it go, right? What happens when I totally lie to
my my voters? When I don't do anything I promised them? Oh, nothing?
They still vote for me? Cool. Just give up any chance of making
a change, I guess. Chance of that. That's why it's important
to reach out to those people. Get them to watch something else.
But I don't I agree with you. Yes. They should watch Hasan. Yeah.
They shouldn't. They should watch They should watch me instead.
Yeah, but I feel like the fact that he he's So, what you just
said, Hasan knows this, which is part of his platforming strategy.
This is why he doesn't go on with adversarial content creators
cuz he doesn't want any of his audience to be taken away.
I I just find You'll only lose >> The idea The The idea
of the debate as I understood it was should we go on the same
platform as Hasan. And the things that I was thinking of were
like Soy Pill going on that Progressive Victory thing. Or, you
know, the instances where Hasan is engaged with creators like
This Ryan Getty guy is really funny. I I just don't But if we're
if we're moving the debate to like does Hasan ever engage
other people that don't agree with him?
I just don't really understand what the debate is because there's
nothing actionable here. So, here's the Listen to what I'm saying.
There's nothing to change. Okay, here. This is what I foresee.
This is the path that I feel like we're on. And unfortunately,
I feel like it's the path we're probably going to go down. Let
me know anytime if you disagree at any point of this, okay? I
think that we're going to spend the next few months with a whole
bunch of people debating on whether or not the far lefties or
people like Hasan should be welcomed into our coalition. And
at some point, it's going to come down to this kind of strategic
big tent thing of like, "Well, yeah, we should let more people
in." Not understanding how big tents work. We're going to end
up having these people as being larger parts of our media and
campaign cycles than they ever should be. They're going to advocate
almost exclusively for completely unelectable candidates. And
they're going to be pushing the Democratic Party into having
strong positions on issues where the majority of voters are not
at that are only going to turn off people from voting. And
Like being pro-Israel. Like being pro-Israel all the time. Once
those unelectable primary candidates, most of them are going
to lose their primaries anyway, all of those far lefty people
are then going to morph mutate into the next thing. You You know,
you bring up all these people on the on the Progressive Victory
Panel. One of those people is Nina Turner, who as soon as she
started losing her race started blaming AIPAC and the for funding
her campaign opponents anyway. So, all of those people Uh dude.
The This guy
We just watched a clip of him doing the same thing, which is
very funny. He'll say it's just a joke, but I don't know. It's
a real problem. Whatever. People now that you worked with, that
you were, you know, making deals with the devil with, are now
going to become your number one haters, just like when Bernie
lost the primary to Hillary the first time. They said that it
was because of the the super delegates were rigging it against
him. And then when he lost the second time, it's because all
of the moderates came together and backstabbed him and worked
with Biden. Like Can do anything about Okay, we cannot change
what the Democratic Party is going to do. Well, we are. That's
what we >> can do is we can decide we can decide Okay,
listen, please. Please. We can decide whether or not we want
to engage with him or not. That's what we can decide. We can
decide if we want to engage with him or not. If I wanted to influence
the Democratic Party, I would go work at a think tank and go
work some place where they actually pay attention.
I I
What should the engagement look like? Like this is the point
of like the influencers arguing, the people writing the op-eds,
the people that are writing the Substack, the people that are
on Twitter. This is the argument right now is what should
Does Destiny not know about the Third Way article? Does he not
know who wrote it? Does he not know why they wrote it? Does he
not know why it's circulating around media right now?
Does he not know any of these things? What does he know?
Who does he think Ryan's talking about?
How does he think this whole thing got
Does he think this is because of Dan?
I will I will give Dan his flowers here. The Third Way people
used all of his talking points. But like the reason it's going
to CNN, the reason it's coming up in all these places is because
of the Third Way op-ed, okay? So, are do we cooperate these people
like they're our ideological teammates or are these people adversaries
that we need to be doing combat with? That's the big debate right
now, right? And everybody's having a little say in like what
direction they want to push the party towards.
Yeah, and the disagreement comes from fundamentally, do you think
getting Hasan to help a person like Ro Khanna into Congress does
less to help than he's going to do to hurt the Democratic
by engaging with him? He's going to do that anyway in the general.
But if you think that that I just laid out was the path that
I think is the most likely to happen. If there's some part of
that that you think is unlikely or unreasonable, then I I I have
not seen the data to say that this is potentially going to be
the case and I'm confident enough that it's going to happen.
And also, when you say like all these unelectable candidates,
but a bunch of these guys do get elected like the people that
he does elect for them. We're currently dealing with the fallout
of the last time we ignored progressives. Like they they retconned
our entire set of rhetoric. They like dragged the entire country
into a mire of goddamn identitarian
and MAGA learned their full set of goddamn tricks from these
people. And we're going to let them do it all over again. These
people
I Bro, we're Maybe she didn't have a
Destiny was full-on out here advocating for trans youth medicine
like the whole time. No, you have to let kids transition. It's
important you do that cuz if they hit puberty, there's no other
way back for them.
Destiny is those people.
Why are you saying the progressives? Any of the Dude, Destiny
was out here doing all the arguments for that. What Why are we
pretending otherwise? I I don't get it. I don't think it makes
any sense to say that MAGA learned their tricks from the far
left. I think that's But that's not Are you kidding? Fribbling
snowflake woke like like like woke scolding purity testing. I
think absolutely the structure of MAGA is falls directly in line
with a lot of the structure of Yeah, I don't think I think that's
the I'm sorry. I'm sorry. And I know we're supposed to be on
the same team here, but I think
I think that I know that we're supposed to be on the same team
here, but
No, Ryan Getty. You're out of the coalition. You don't support
the party, aka agreeing with me. Supporting the party means agreeing
with me. Dude, shut up. Shut the [__] up. No, I think
that that is removing agency from the neo-fascist Republican
Party. I don't think that they learned from the left in terms
of implementing their agenda. They have a full-throated,
fully developed system where they Okay.
there's no way this Every This person's like sole DNA
is that of like a woke scold leftist from 2015.
Okay? Every single foundational
foundational atomic particle in this person's body is like a
2015 SJW.
Look at Look at the reaction to when Ryan like disagreed. fascist
Republican Party. I don't think that they learned
Are you sure about that, sweetie? Are you sure about that, sweety?
Grabs the glasses. the left in terms of implementing their agenda.
They have a full Oh, okay. Okay, then. >> that they learned
from the left in terms of the glasses. Okay. Okay. Okay. We watch
the hand. We watch the hand. Talk to the hand cuz the face ain't
having it, Ryan. Talk to the hand cuz the face ain't having it,
Ryan.
I'm sorry. Just everything about this woman is like 2015
Tumblr SJW leftist, okay?
Is that a mullet? Maybe.
I just I It's crazy that she's talking about woke scolding the
left. I It's wild. their agenda. They have a full-throated,
fully developed system where they can do this stuff all on their
own. I think it is crazy, actually, to blame
to blame the far left for MAGA. That's fine. I did, though. Okay.
And I would Yeah, you're wrong. You're wrong. Incredibly wrong.
Hold on.
Hold on. Let Let Destiny go for a minute. Hey, wait. Do y'all
agree with this? Do you blame Do you blame the far left for causing
MAGA? I don't blame the far left for causing MAGA, but I blame
the far left with like What are you saying, then? for getting
us used to the kind of like from pathos from ethos arguments
that like That's just populism.
That's That's literally just populism. That's just arguing Dude.
>> The style that the far left has used in MAGA has copied
it. I don't know if I agree with this. I think it was No, I disagree
with that entirely. The The far right has been a problem in this
country for far longer than the far left.
the far left invited invented this thing called demagoguery.
And then Trump co-opted it. Isn't that crazy? Sure. I asked you
a direct question, though. Whether How many bombs did the Weather
Underground start I'm not going to sit here. I'm not going to
sit here and have y'all say that the far left is the reason that
MAGA is a problem. That's >> far left taught MAGA its current
rhetoric. No. But [laughter] that's ridiculous, man.
I'm sorry. That's ridiculous.
I don't I don't agree with this perspective, but the if we look
I Dude, nobody agrees with her at all. She just said some insane
[__] and These people are at least not laughing at
her, but uh Soy Pill, no such compunction, okay? Soy Pill has
been trying to contain laughter this entire time. Soy Pill is
like dying over here. >> 2024. Like do we feel like the
the far left wing Do we feel like this was helpful or or harmful
when it came to the general election? No, but that's not what
I'm vehemently disagreeing with >> No, I agree. I agree.
I'm I'm not I'm not repeating that argument. I'm just bringing
it back to the in terms of like courting them again. Do we feel
like the far left was helpful or harmful in the 2024 election?
They were harmful because they didn't vote for the Democratic
candidate. Or at least the ones that didn't vote for the Democratic
candidate were harmful. Yeah. Well, then why do we think Why
do we think it's going to change time
when the election choice in 2024 was the easiest election choice
it's probably ever going to be? It's not, but we're not saying
it will. We're saying why not help use them to promote other
candidates that we agree are good if they're going to Yeah, but
I'm just I'm telling you that that was a disaster in 2024. So,
why do we think it's going to work? You got to cut out all these
like anti-Israel people now because if we keep going with them,
they're going to eventually show people the videos of the bombings
in Lebanon
of what Gaza looks like today. Eventually people will see this
and then I won't be able to run defense for Israel anymore. I
will have TO SWITCH POSITIONS. THAT IS THE WORST CASE SCENARIO.
We need to support Israel. We need to give them bombs. We need
to let them rain down death and destruction and darkness on everybody.
It's operation eternal darkness, guys. What's going to change
this time? When did we work with the far left to promote candidates
we agree on and it was a disaster.
The far left was part of the left. What do you mean? They were
we were all seen as being on quote unquote the same team. What
do you mean? Like can you address
on his on stream multiple times. He was out at marches giving
speeches to people or whatever talking to people. I'm
sure
Who is the far left? Bernie Sanders and AOC were on Hassan's
stream. Hassan was out giving speeches to people.
What the [__] are you talking about?
I mean like politically, where did we work with the far left
and it worked out poorly for us? What what Answer the question.
You didn't you didn't even come close to answering the question.
team. What do you mean? Like can you the left? What do you mean?
They were I maybe Destiny just can't listen to people and absorb
information anymore. Maybe there's just something totally broken
there. When did we work with the far left to promote candidates
we agree on and it was a disaster.
The far left was part of the left. What do you mean? They were
we were all seen So you're arguing that working with the far
left would be a disaster for you.
Okay, that's what the argument is. And Soy Pill goes, "Wait,
when have we done that in the past and it's been a
Destiny says, "We were all the same thing back in the day."
Not a not a response.
Literally to just totally incoherent. being as being on quote
unquote the same team. What do you mean? Like can you
So can you just address Bernie Sanders AOC was on Hassan's stream
multiple times? Hassan was out at marches giving speeches to
people or whatever talking Hassan was out at marches giving speeches
to people or whatever. talking to people.
Um I'm sure there But there's three of them. So there are other
far left examples. So the far left is AOC, Bernie Sanders, and
So when did working with Hassan, Bernie, and AOC work out in
disaster for us?
That's what Soy Pill is asking.
I just I have it paused. I don't know what happened to the cameras.
But it's just funny that like How is nearly a Biden ask answer?
That was nearly like a Biden 2024
debate answer of like not even close to answering the question.
Not even close to like providing a complete thought. He landed
it at the end, okay, in a way Biden could Did what I'm suggesting
happen when Hassan promoted a candidate that liberals also want
and we used that? The candidate promotion is like one of the
least important parts of this entire model. So I don't know why
you're fixating on on
That's the reason you criticized Soy Pill in the first place.
That's the reason you were filling your diaper. So that's what
he's concerned about. Hey, you filled your diaper at me working
with Progressive Victory. You filled your diaper. So now explain
why you filled your diaper. And Destiny's like
It's not even a big deal. It's not even a big deal. Why are you
asking me about that? It's not even a big deal. Well, you made
it a big deal.
That's he's just trying to figure out why you made it a big deal.
the utility that I'm talking about. I mean, I don't know what
else you're talking about, but >> I'm talking about the
control of the rhetoric, the thing that like was the most important
thing, the thing that actually mattered. It feels like the whole
anti-Palestinian marches movement and the obsession related to
the Israel-Palestine All of these issues
Just I don't care if you go with them. We just can't let them
badmouth Israel. We just can't What the They were
That's the bad part.
By the way, the the problem Destiny has is that they were calling
it a genocide.
I don't know how you disconnect this from the fact that directionally
every single person he's complaining about was correct.
Not not maybe not in method cuz guess what? Anti-Semites could
still call this out. But the things they were saying, the alarm
bell they were ringing was correct. Israel is doing war crimes.
Israel is wiping Gaza off the map. Israel is killing people.
They're starving people. All of these things were correct.
So when you go out and you are objectively saying, "I really
wish these people had been less upset about the genocide that
was objectively happening and carried out and I ran defense for."
Why are you saying this? Why did you convene a panel to have
this be the core point you're making? That these people were
too loud about the war crimes being done with American weapons
and American taxpayer dollars.
Why did you convene a panel for this? I have announcement to
make. I think Hassan was too loud about all of the people dying
and Gaza being wiped off the map and the genocide and the starving
Palestinians, okay? I think he's too loud about it. The idea
that like the far left was the issue that drove this wedge and
not that people in general were upset with the Israeli policies.
Like this is a consequence of the policy, not hey, like let's
make this bad. >> No, it wasn't. It's not a consequence
of Israel bombing the [__] out of Palestine. It's
not a consequence of that, guys. If you were a real person, you
would just like minimize that as much as possible so you could
vote for Kamala with no concessions for her. How about How about
we just go in the human direction and say, "Well, if you're a
human being with a heart at all, you say that hey, I required
for my candidate to denounce this, to say that they will put
a stop to it." And that's crazy that he said no there. I didn't
catch that Soy Pill said this this is a consequence of Israel's
policies. That's how you know, by the way, that Destiny hasn't
sincerely switched position
on Israel. He is just going to put a mask on and and like move
over I'm to I'm I'm literally going to use his rhetoric. That
he's going to put a mask on and try to move over on it so he
doesn't get his ass blown out so he can actually move with the
Democratic Party. All right? But it is totally fake.
Soy Pill just said, "I think this was driven, you know, the anger
was driven by Israeli policies, Israeli war crimes, Israeli action."
And Destiny goes, "No, no, no, no, no, no." wasn't because any
intelligent reasonable person that has an intelligent or reasonable
view on foreign policy would have known that if you cared about
Palestinians, that the easiest option there would be to vote
for Kamala. That's it's not even in >> Yeah. The the That
wasn't the driving factor of the wedge. But but the Israel-Palestine
stuff disaffecting voters did not come from Hassan and Israel-Palestine
in the No, it did. It did. No, the Israel-Palestine should have
been a mobilizing issue for us on the left. It became Why did
Larry Ellison buy TikTok, guys? Why do you think Larry Ellison
bought TikTok?
Oh, have a good night. It's late and I need to get going. I'm
glad I was forwarded to your channel. Oh, what's up, Crutchy?
Thank you very much. I I assume you came from Ogre Boy. Oh, I
didn't do the shoutout for Ogre Boy. SO
Ogre Boy 6. Does that work?
Nice. Go follow Ogre Boy 6. Yes. divisive issue for us on the
left. The far left used to attack us. That should have been a
rallying cry. Kamala Harris is calling for a full ceasefire.
Kamala, do you think like there's no con full ceasefire.
Yeah. Were Israelis honoring ceasefires? Were Israelis listening
at all? I That's that's the best we could do, guys, is maybe
you stop dying for a little bit. Maybe. Yeah, but there's no
So when you had Biden and he said he had red red lines and so
the signaling from the Democratic Party is we're not going to
stop this and that's what everyone >> But Biden did. Biden
stopped several things from happening. He made them he delayed
their encroachment into Rafa for like a week or two until they
moved a
he's so lost on having this conversation. It's actually
>> He delayed like the death, destruction, starvation.
He delayed all this for like a week. Brother, are you serious?
Are you are you
Dude, this is
It's just mind-blowing that he could make these arguments. It's
mind-blowing, man. It's crazy.
Right, but the
point is it wasn't enough. So the Democrats' inability to prevent
it was driving the disaffectation. It wasn't the fact that the
left was like, "Ah, guys, I know they're good on it, but this
is why they're actually bad." It was like, "No, people have legitimate
criticisms of the way the Democrats are handling this." literally
tried to like science fiction in like a like a
pier that we brought in from like the
That was used for what, Destiny? Oh god.
What was that pier used for, Destiny?
Cuz I think it basically got up immediately for supplies. They
eventually did start getting supplies in, okay? But it got up
it got up pretty quickly. What's the like everything everybody
knows it was used for? What what what was that used for most
chiefly that everyone knows it was used for? That is the hostage
rescue operation that resulted in like hundreds of dead Palestinians
getting shot in the streets. Right? Which again, you rescued
your hostages, whatever. But like
Yeah, I think over 100 civilians died in this rescue operation.
I think you should have a caveat that if you're an influencer
and you try to like go against Hassan, that you're going to get
harassed. So you should tell people that as well because his
audience is like no other. They are probably
Again, back here. The Like you know what this is, right? They're
trying to paint me as like Hassan's audience. But it's like,
dude, at one, I I was definitely covering a lot of Hassan stuff.
While his his audience was incapable for us. I don't know. They
they never said anything to me. Is he trying to pretend that
like I'm Hassan's audience? Is that Is that what he's
some of the meanest people on the
But Yeah, okay. Like everyone of Hassan's is going to have their
snarkers. That's I do want to get to uh Oh my god, that was I
had one tweet yesterday about Hassan and I absolutely got threatened
to get doxxed and people were in Every audience is going to have
their snarkers. Oh my god, that's a crazy statement.
Dude, it's actually it's just Yeah, I
Woof. And they're being like >> it's Taylor Lorenz's Twitter
for the past. Holy and again this is not exclusive. I know Destiny
you had to change every rule you had to change your subreddit
rules if somebody disagrees with. You had to change your subreddit
rules if somebody disagrees with. I had to change No, I had to
change my subreddit rules because I don't like it when my audience
types mean things about people. Hassan actively encourages his
audience to do things that are more or less the equivalent of
doxxing, swatting
This is just Destiny. Destiny So, Destiny's just trying to muddy
the waters. Destiny objectively does these
Destiny has literally called for me to be killed
in front of his audience. Sorry, in a interview he knew would
be
So, Destiny has tried to dox me, Destiny has called for my death,
and then he has the balls to say Hassan has done this. I thought
I did dude, this is wild. This is actually wild to watch.
Very crazy. Harassment, abuse, he lit- again, he literally read
out the full doxes of every single person that was listed on
Progressive Victory and showed it on Twitch with that up in that.
Nothing even remotely similar to that. There aren't There aren't
right-wingers that that would mobilize their audience in such
a
Dude, I can't believe how like cynical this is. I can't believe
how insanely cynical this is that Destiny's trying to paint Hassan
in the way that he operated to try to make it okay. You know
why he's doing that, right? Because if he can convince people
that Hassan did it, too, people aren't walking away from Hassan,
right?
So, they're they're trying to pretend that Hassan's done these
things to anywhere near the extent Destiny has because then it's
not a line other people can draw for not interacting with Destiny.
But I don't think So, we could go through it again. I don't I
think Hassan went through those PV documents. He said it wasn't
doxxing because it was all publicly like it was all publicly
disclosed information or something, right? But I don't know if
he read out all of the info
for one, and ultimately
that was done in like a political video in a political context
or politics, right? Totally disavowed shouldn't have been done.
In fact, I think he should have gotten banned for it for at least
some period of time. But it's like it's not him over like basically
being called out, trying to dox people, calling for their death,
encouraging as much harassment as
It's like not the same thing. It's not even close. So, Progressive
Victory and showed it on Twitch with that up in that. Nothing
even remotely similar to
There aren't right-wingers that that would mobilize their audience
in such a way. Destiny doxes, DGG is not worse. DGG is far worse
than Hassan. DGG is far worse than Hassan. It's not even close.
It's not even a little bit close. When has Hassan ever gone and
posted stuff to doxbins and published that in his chat?
Something Destiny has done. Doxbin being a site explicitly for
swatters that according to Destiny himself is explicitly for
swatting. And Destiny has done this multiple times. This is not
Destiny's audience doing it, either. This is Destiny doing it
and publishing it to his audience directly.
way. The crazy like weird leftie people This is No, don't you
swept. You swept hard. It's okay. You swept hard. You said every
community has a snarkers. Nothing is like what exists on the
on the left today. Nothing is like what exists on the left today.
The point I'm making is that this is wrong. Ground for dismissal
because I think that like if you No, but he said it was ground
for dismissal. He just said to be aware that when you interact
with these people you are going to receive probably the worst
harassment you've ever gotten anywhere in the world. He wants
information. We sweep for them. Why wouldn't they harass
We sweep for them. Why wouldn't they harass you? Just keep talking
over Soy Pill. I'm sure he's going to forget whatever his argument
is if you just keep talking over Soy Pill. You're one of the
strongest like centrist warriors. Of course you are. I'm literally
I'm calling Hassan tankie terrorist all the time.
Dude, it's it's actually I didn't realize they broke down like
this for the the cult shaming ritual that he's just screaming
Now he's just screaming that you're sweeping for lefties. You're
sweeping for tankies. This is actually really awesome.
Didn't Destiny suggest that people post Hassan's location when
he does IRL streams? Yes, that there should be a live tracker
of where Hassan's location is at protests that he goes to. By
the way, like left-wing protests.
And like I don't know Yeah, but you're saying that there's like
an ideological value here to collaborating with him and he knows
there is because he's using you while you think you're using
him. So, of course the By the way, the I So, Soy Pill basically
is starting to I assume get the impression that if he goes any
further he's going to actually put his own safety in danger because
Destiny has doxxed multiple people who have continued to say
like the things he's done wrong. The last time Destiny attempted
to make this point, Soy Pill asked him, wait, are you serious
right now? You've doxxed people multiple times, right? And Soy
Pill, you know, he's already had that interaction. I can only
assume he's a little spooked by some of the the things that have
been said to him since he had that interaction. He doesn't want
to say it again, it seems like. Well, who knows? Maybe he will.
Sweeping is is going to be preferential for them. How was he
using me if he's got the platform that's a thousand times bigger
than me? >> Because he's got because he's got people like
you defending the fact that he's, you know, a useful person and
are part of the discourse of encouraging all of the other libs
to work with them. That's his like biggest campaign So, hold
on. Now Now I have to actually go back and re-listen to what
Soy Pill's question was? He's got the plat- him. So, of course
the sweeping is going to be preferential for them. How was he
using me if he's got the platform that's a thousand times bigger
than me? How was he [clears throat] using me if he's got the
platform a thousand times bigger than me? Because he's got people
like you defending the fact So, how how is he using me? Because
you're defending the fact that he's, you know, a useful person
or like part of the discourse of encouraging all the other libs
to work with them. So, basically he's because you benefit from
him and you're enticed
that is and and you do benefit
Yeah, because you benefit from him, you're going to tell other
people you benefit from him and you don't see the downside. There
is no downside, by the way. There's no downside for Soy Pill.
There's no downside for the movement. The downside is you
are helping him to encourage other libs to work with him by I
assume having like a good experience working with him.
right now he's trying to convince the Democratic Party to work
with him and be a part of his project.
So, just it's wrong to work with Hassan. It's just wrong to work
with Hassan in general. In a general sense, it's wrong to work
with Hassan.
Because he's got because he's got people like you defending the
fact that he's, you know, a useful person and are part of the
discourse of encouraging all the other libs to work with them.
That's his like biggest campaign right now on the internet is
trying to convince the Democratic Party to work with him and
to be a part of his project. Yeah, and do you think I'm the one
primarily driving out the fact that all the politicians are already
doing this? Like No, I think you're primarily I think you're
the largest figure driving it. That's what I said, I think. I
He's a part of it, sure. So, so like dude, Soy Pill is basically
asking when he does that snarky little So, you think I'm the
main person driving it or he's saying like where do you think
the apportionment of blame would go here? And do you think I
could stop this? Do you think me or even a thousand creators
on my side not working with him would stop this? Look at Ryan's
face. What's Ryan's face been like the whole
Good question. What has it been like? His project. Yeah, and
do you think I'm the one primarily driving out the fact that
all the politicians are already doing this? Like clearly okay
with No, I think you're primarily I think you're the largest
figure driving it. That's what I said, I think. Do you think
I'm even like making a dent in it or am I like, hey, I think
these Democrats actually have like something to gain from this?
Actually, no, actually that's a good point, I think. If you're
not like making a noticeable dent in the public sphere, I think
that none of your behavior actually matters whatsoever. So, you
should basically just do whatever you want.
Hypothetical, will you were up two
and you were up two seconds and you were up two seconds and you
were up two seconds and you were up two seconds and you were
up two I'm not trying to be obtuse. Okay.
Now, normally I discount anything Mr. Mouton has to say because
he's
But he is like peak useful idiot. So, you know, sometimes you
got to take the hands-on experience. That's got to convince you
sometimes, right? If there's anybody who knows something about
being a useful idiot, it's got to be Mouton. No?
Come on.
Okay. I think this is a good time to read super Dude, this Ryan
Getty guy is based. What the He's basically just like, yeah,
I'm I'm out. This is This is totally unproductive. I'm I'm just
going to go.
So, he like mutes at some point and says this, okay? Democrats
are handling
We're at the point where the debate has moved from should we
engage with Hassan
Hassan never engages with the us
and now and and now there's nothing actionable about this debate.
This debate is totally
devolved into a drama slot panel. There's nothing actionable
being talked about here. Nothing at all. This is completely pointless
at this point and I really don't appreciate what Wick was trying
to do there. I think that that is
a really sketchy move from a moderator,
Democrats are
Wow. $5 He read my tweet disagreeing with Monster. I'm not saying
this doesn't happen, but it's not inevitable like it happens
every time. So, you can stop saying sweeping. I'm not saying
his audience is good and he doesn't sick them after people. It's
disgusting behavior, but it's not some inevitability because
he read my incredibly critical tweet of him on a stream and I
did not get a single Hassan snarker in my Twitter DMs. Somehow
I probably just got lucky, though.
I mean $5 Most of the time What happens when Destiny disagrees
with you, Soy Pill? Oh, wait, that was the last time you were
on and you said DGGers in your DMs telling you to yourself repeatedly.
Also, I just want to be clear. When I say always and never I
don't actually mean 100.00% of the time on all those things.
Usually I mean most of the time or So, I'm just to be clear on
that, right? I just My only slight disagreement there was I'm
not sure to which Don't get me wrong. It's worse when he's actively
promoting it and he does, but like to what extent the level of
this like snarkerism and brigading unique to that. Yeah. Yeah.
I've driven home drunk like 20 times. I'm not going to wreck
yet. I don't think I was ever like that. I don't think I was
ever like [laughter] that.
$5 You should be more careful when you are drunk cuz you know
you're more prone to get into an accident. Like I've never driven
home 10 miles an hour before unless I'm wasted. I don't know
if I got into an accident. $5 from Harvey Marvey. Everyone on
this panel knows or should know the kind of harassment Destiny
does towards and directs at Pixie. Dan knows, Moot knows, Wick
knows. It's crazy. $5 from Jari. Oh, we just don't mention we
Yeah, yeah. Oh, gee, that's crazy. That's crazy. Destiny, my
mom watches you on TikTok. Ooh. This whole Tell what it means.
$5 from Board to Ready. We lost nothing by It's It's just It's
really funny,
By the way, Pixie didn't do something like crazy like harass
Destiny on TikTok. She's the person who had her shared by Destiny
without her permission.
Like amateur they shot together and he didn't have her consent
to share it and then he shared it with somebody he'd known for
a week.
Uh a sex worker on Twitter that he didn't really verify the identity
of at all. Actually, he He explicitly can't have ident- [clears throat]
or verified the identity at all cuz he got catfished. So,
shared the the video they shot together after a week.
And then tried to argue to his audience that she consented to
that. She obviously provided implied consent to that even though
that's insane cuz there's no reason he should have trusted her.
And then when when she found out when it when it all got leaked
from that account, he then told her that he really trusted this
person a lot, an 18-year-old sex worker from Twitter that he'd
known for a week.